[Music]
thank you
yo I checked my check
we are back the realm is back home with
hopefully better audio
real talk to me let me go on my levels
are sounding how we doing out here
a little tired ain't gonna lie to you
it's been a roughly a lot of stuff going
on
[Music]
a lot of Lords got stuff going on the
attic coming in hot take that stuff
songs got stuff
we gotta give it up
to the people oh you gonna hear that
energy you ain't gonna like me Donna
Taco you ain't gonna like me today I'm
just gonna get that out to away
what's going on let's get them real cool
I gotta Echo
so again
[Music]
on your side too
what's up man we in here
okay
[Music]
still hearing it yeah all right we'll go
figure it out
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right figuring out this Echo thing I
know it's still going on y'all I got a
addicted some stuff
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
all right the audio issues continuing
we still figuring this thing out y'all
I got my main attic on the check-in on
the testing
continuing
we still figure this together
audio issues the plague the curse of the
audio issues continues
now coming home unbelievable
all right so mute the desktop audio
because they do hear me talk
um
there you go
yeah we live y'all
and the audio issues have what's up son
we got the audio issues continuing now
at home
we love you hot
he tested though
what's up what's up
yeah yeah
all right talk again yo yo my check my
check
attic testing testing with addict go
ahead and mute the desktop audio though
yo yo yo my check my check audio's hot
1000 audio checks
take one week off facts
so it's literally it's literally was
picking up but that's crazy all right
hold on we're gonna see we're gonna see
though I don't trust it we're gonna see
we're gonna put the Stars soon joints
all right
how about that
[Music]
testing testing
beautiful as ever Mike is good it's that
rapper the music is bad
music is bad yeah you're gonna you're
gonna have to meet Dallas's bars
[Music]
so we can actually hear all right
testing testing testing one two three yo
yo desktop audios and all of that what's
good what's good
how we doing yeah it's the Pax audio
plagues too still it's important this
y'all still haunting this
they don't want us to be great
I think I would do
so far so good
they don't want us to be great so we
guess we ain't got no music today
so far so much
that I want us to be great so we guess
we ain't got no music I don't know
what's going on it's picking up
something in the background it's still
doing it now
let me know y'all
um what if y'all hearing us because the
the packs plague is continuing but we
need to make sure this thing is legit
might check my check what's going on you
you guys looking how's looking talk to
me
you talk back to me I'm talking I'm
talking to you
ten toes down so Oscar to you sounded
good so it's something with the beats
[Music]
uh what's good though they said we good
it's just so it got to be the boss we
got to figure out the ball's joint
another time am I still there yeah yeah
no okay so the wildest thing in the
world just happened you know you love
hot and cameras on me I know I don't
care I'm telling you no I'm not gonna
say nothing wrong with it right now
I'm just trying to save my man just in
case you go off
what's good what you got to say before
we get into it nothing
just stay quiet yo I got can they see me
yeah we live y'all can see me yo yo yo
so I had this thing right yeah and I was
sitting there and I had a skit I had a
skit and and cuphead goes
hello
a rapper want to see a dead body
sure
you ever seen the PlayStation 4
PlayStation 5 vr2.
this is what happens when we have
musical issues and we about to make up
our own content this is what happens
all right
let people moved the pig is he out of
pocket all right and we are finally live
through issues you're unity and welcome
to the iron Lords podcast LLC and live
on lordsofgaming.net episode number 298
this is another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table or the Lord's
date and today we've got E3 canceled
gave past friends and family Congress
versus Sony in Japan
Last of Us PC
psvr too
PS5 and Resident Evil 4 remake sales to
discuss so we go get right into it you
missed something what I missed yeah man
baby you missed big oh yeah you're right
dude this live podcast
[Music]
for returning from packs Lords my
co-host with the cold most my brother
from Alabama the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his old world and the
how of the young wolf my man Lord attic
Fresh Off The Move still moving how we
doing
yeah I'm on my laptop right now uh it's
not my normal camera I actually had to
do something different huh I like the
new place yeah
it looks like you can breathe well like
eventually I'm gonna have this desk all
the way back because like this is like
in the middle of the room like it's not
even where it's supposed to be the
computer's not hooked up I have my
Elgato light not even like connected to
anything like it's just sitting there
yeah you look at Christmas it's good
yeah
baby that's all you need this I needed a
2.5
inch wrench to to be able to to get a
camera but I have one so I had to send
Zachary to the store so when he gets
here I'm gonna have to mute and actually
hook up the camera so it's just it's
been a disaster yeah
wow movies horrible it's hard I don't
like those
things like I'm never moving again
you're good
you don't know what got God for you but
if I'm a whole lot of them hold on
get to cool down hell no
pretty much like
the new
the new thing is I have like a whole
Space dedicated just the podcast yeah I
won't have like my bed in the background
stuff like right now so we don't go into
the nasty areas right now right now it's
like showing this like a technology is
like McDonald's it's connected to my
kitchen oh okay that's what my my goal
is to move this back all the way and get
another smaller desk
and put a diagonal to what I have now
and put another monitor on that desk
with my camera facing this this way
random feet
I can't help but people decide to come
oh I'm gonna miss I'm gonna miss the you
know yelling at Zachary
[Laughter]
right here
foreign
[Laughter]
the Lord of clarity lord patreon of the
BET of the iron bank and PC Master race
Lord Sovereign
good sweating up a storm because it's
starting to warm up here in New York
City got all these damn lights on me
yeah so it's warming up here but I'm
good doing good got got a little bit of
rest paxis was a little bit
must be nice let's get rest yeah I know
every night again I didn't know what's
so funny people try to disturb that
wrestling and I'll be like not that they
say
and even I mean again when we were at
Pax bro we got to for what king and I
usually sleep yeah we got to sleep in
right yeah they matter though
we didn't take our narcotics with us
I left I left my focus at home yeah okay
okay and for me it was the coffee I was
rocking without coffee for like the
first two or three days just because it
was like inconvenient to get it for
whatever reason right it was just like
ah so I just like I'm a rock without it
no brother
that last day on the show floor I had my
coffee I was like yeah
he walks up to me right I don't know
what the hell he's talking about so he
because he was drinking his coffee early
that Dunkin Donuts crap
but it had it has the caffeine
yeah
I'm mad I'm mad as hell so he walks up
to me and I'm standing there with the
camera in the jump and I got that same
face I'm like man I ain't got no C4 I
need to get I need something and this
dude goes yo king I said what
the hell is wrong with you it's coffee
it's coffee
wow yeah I was like yo and you just saw
it on his whole energy his body was
higher it was it was different it was it
was different so yeah I cannot allow
that to happen again good I mean we had
a good time it was productive there was
a couple logistic things just about the
way the show is where more people are on
the show floor that it a little
disappointing but we'll talk about that
more more link but it was good in terms
of gaming so I I played a little bit
Tales From The Master race this week
we uh yeah re4 got to play some of that
not a lot playing it on Hardcore and
yeah them zombies trying to kill you
those those Spaniards are real like and
I'm not playing
so the funny thing is did you know it
was funny about that is that they mean
even in a zombie-like state they
maintain the way they articulate the
Spaniards speak with the th they they
still speak that way like I'm gonna kill
you
yeah fluid
yeah it's a zombie or not they gotta
make sure you know
so it's really good it's cool how they
change things around to like the
original game wasn't about jump scare so
much as it was about the sense of of
dread of them constantly coming at you
and but when they give you more control
in this one right you're like how do
they maintain that well they they throw
many more of them at you right and then
your movement
he has cool things to do right he has a
periods things like that but at the same
time he's still not dipping and dodging
like he's not he doesn't really exhibit
all the super agent powers are you
implying that he's bad basic with it
yeah he kind of basic like the parry and
he's gangster but he's not you know
dodging out of a dodging and pairing
like it's it's still a little stiff and
that's purposeful right to maintain that
sense of dread when they're coming at
you
um but it's I'm loving it so far I'm
enjoying that um and then I have thing I
said I need to turn on the the dead
sister oh wait wait what's that what
system is that with that
I finally I finally yo this is the only
the second time I got to play my damn
psvr too so I just gotta throw this on
so I got on there finally
[Laughter]
head first so I got but I got to play
Moss I played res infinite I played a
little more of uh color Mountain I
played um a little while I said I played
thumb called a while yeah uh Thumper man
I love Thumper so but Thumper and VR
yeah
they're doing this all over
he brought it like 12 times
like Resident Evil uh four I brought
like 12 times
um yes I was playing that fun stuff I
got it I still gotta pick up my demio
because I'm getting it I gotta get that
dmio
yeah so I played that and then I played
a little bit of the show MLB the Show
23. who did that before you play
baseball yes let's play ball yeah who
did that before you play baseball
baseball hey guys
ah he has to play baseball so I haven't
played much of the game game proper I
just went right into the the Negro
League story stuff and uh went into the
Satchel Page story yeah yeah he's such a
character dude but Satchel Paige was was
just next level like
that the people
you know what's dope they got the little
Nuance with the names of the pitches
what yeah yeah like because he was he
like he had a name for every single
pitch and it was not the normal name but
you know Sasha page or something else
man and I like the in playing it the
little scenarios come off a little bit
boring because because you just you're
satisfying whatever you know thing they
want you to do strike out all these
battles whatever but it's cool to see
how it differentiates from the actual
the main game where it's like yes the
stadiums look like old stadiums you see
people dressed in suit and tie and like
the pedicure more athletic yeah they
wasn't athletic back then it was just
you know but but I'm just joking yeah
big guts in my little segregation joke
but I I love specifically because you go
through different scenarios the Satchel
Pages career right that's the only one
I've done so far and you get to the one
that is like famous right the infamous
one way is like they're playing the
monarchs are playing an exhibition game
against like a semi-pro team that's all
white right and the first batter uh gets
like a dribbling inside hit against
statue page and then one of the players
calls out like oh he's just a little he
says he literally says oh he's just the
average doctor he ain't nothing
literally says it that way wow that's
what he says so Satchel says
all right cool bring the whole team in
Oh you mean bring the Outfield in a
little bit no no bring the whole team
into the infield and have them sit down
in the infield I got this and such and
he he did this more than once in his
career Satchel proceeded to strike out
the next three batters no one touched
them he didn't need a team behind us and
then there was others there were other
scenarios I never even know in other
times where he would continue to do this
and every batter he would get out he
would remove one more player from the
field until it was just him and the
catcher that's crazy and that's all he
needed that's how good Saturday that's
crazy wow okay me as an owner would have
looked over at that and said I don't
give a damn if we don't got no blacks in
here I need him on my spot yeah
but that you know what it is there's a
reason why Jackie was the first and not
Satchel Satchel
exactly
yeah money Leroy listen me as an owner I
would have got him I don't care first of
all once you once I would have saw that
my dollar signs is different yeah I
would have been like I got him and then
he would have had more secret service
around him than the president
I'm winning game it's about to ring it's
about the ring it was a different time
but I just love the fact of what they're
doing with the with this story stuff
shout out to the um the I forgot the
gentleman from the uh the museum who's
doing a lot of the narrations
excellent in that yes and telling the
story of each cat and every single it's
like they divide each character's story
into different little like uh points of
their career like big point and ever
before each one he he describes it a
little bit right so there's a like a
video
and it's awesome because again that's
where the learning happens right getting
the chance to play it is cool but again
the scenario isn't exactly how it was
it's just built the best it can be
within the game engine but the fact that
he explains it beforehand it gives you
sort of the context in the background
that's where the learning happens and
then you can't leave that and be like
not be interested in looking up Satchel
Page if you've never you know who statue
page was you gotta by the way who is
this dude a man through 105 and who's
throwing 105 today who's hitting that
bro well but he did that without going
and taking rest and you know all the
stuff that we do to protect pitchers now
then they still get Tommy John for some
weird reason yeah it's just a different
it's just different man and he was and
even within that he was just special
yeah so yeah still it was different yeah
that would be the show for that and
Ramon Russell and team I shot the ball
on Twitter because I was when I was I
played it I was just like man this is
super dope
so that's that's where I'm at no doubt
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the XS gamer the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement ooh beloved
Lord King how are we doing sir
I'm doing fantastic better than uh
Anthony Joshua Anthony Joshua last night
um um oh no it was he got straight edge
nah oh there's a tomato cat no no no oh
yeah Franklin he wasn't a Dominican but
um
Anthony
this is advice you you at the end of
your career
all right and if you don't know what I'm
gonna tell you all right you could be
like Roy and still fight team oh God am
I [__] crazy and embarrassing
yourself or you can listen to me
you have another heavyweight there that
you haven't fought his name is Deontay
Wilder Deontay Wilder's at the end of
his career too he was in two three
brutal fights yeah with a heavyweight
that was bigger and more skilled than he
was not more powerful and he took a
sustain a great beaten in all three of
those fights you and him yeah need to
come together and to hell with everybody
else listen to me it's boatloads of
money for you and you and him to fight
it out and y'all can y'all can stretch
this out three fights y'all can do it
unless you get stretched every fight in
the first round
and I don't believe you have a chance to
beat this man but I do believe y'all
have a chance to gain some money
uh and just right off into the sunset
that's what they need and stop with this
this joke get away from Eddie Hearn
Eddie Hearn is tarnishing you and you're
listening to the wrong stuff all right
so other than that this week I was
playing
fortnite
this seems to be a pattern I saw
something were you playing this Moon
night yeah yeah okay I saw something I
was like Moon night yeah well fortnite
has uh tons of licensed characters yeah
they got tons of Marvel characters
all right so I'm in this Lobby
and I'm playing with my dude five
fingers and he got his other boy in
there
um uh uh 420 tall okay and we are in
there smoking we are
we won seven matches in a row
I'm thinking I'm untouchable I'm God
I've done I did some Godly things in
these matches I recorded all of them
right big Godly things and I'm thinking
it's it's crazy so we're gonna take a
break everybody gotta take a break you
know uh fall 2012 has to go walk his dog
or whatever
I'm like all right 20 minutes we all we
will be all back
so I get my boy Galveston when I'm
coming back and we go in
as we're going there I'm telling five
fingers because five fingers had this
one guy that kept joining and leaving
and I'm cursing this guy out I'm like yo
you keep believing us at a deficit man
we're going to the match and we we're
playing squads or four and there's
always three on four and I'm upset and
he's laughing he's laughing he's
laughing his behind off bro what's up
when I come back we come back later and
I have Galveston with me I'm like yeah
five let's go let's do it we had another
extra dude here this other friend in
there for 2012 wasn't there yet
we flying in and I'm telling them story
I was like yo make sure that room is
locked that your stupid friend don't
keep joining he said yo I got it I gotta
tell you the truth what's going on
what's the truth
he's like nah that's how I cheat the
lobbies wow
oh yes wow he said yeah I know I found
out how to manipulate the lobbies why
I don't ever want to play with you
jacket
I've ever played like the great it was
the greatest I've ever played yo I did
this one thing right they killed my team
yeah my behind ran in there took two
slurp juices ran into the storm grabbed
them ran and got four more slurp juice
I'm doing I had one gun on me got four
more slurp juices revived them drank two
more slurp juices Randy got a shotgun
and killed the other Squad and I'm
throwing my hands in the ambling I'm God
and I was playing Bots
[Laughter]
he stuck a pin in my ego
that that reminds me of title for what
we were playing against by you don't
know if someone bought some are human
places yeah
yo I'm not gonna lie the it that broke
my heart
they look wow funny
he's setting up I don't know what he's
doing yeah I don't like because he was
adjusting his pants
remind me of a certain video of a guy
that you know
and the lead back is the lead back all
right man I'm gonna need you to relax
you was adjusted what was happening
what's happening off camera
yeah you're gonna ask too are you
actually no I really have no idea I
wasn't listening for some of the guys
yeah we just watched you on camera it
was very entertaining you gotta change
that camera angle Papa
that's not I don't know if I need that
Angle now we don't need that engine
right there now let's go back
yeah yeah
don't do that don't do that
widescreen Sideshow
anyway
look man look man so some people are
saying yo you know turn that mouth and
do around man we're not advertising them
[Laughter]
see here's the thing
I I have the the camera because what's
funny is I can actually like switch it
but I have the camera on uh like the
little tripod thing
the desk is fine though I like to do
that yeah there we go go back to that
burn the mountain go back to that yeah
there we go there we go there's too many
there's too many people coming in and
out of this room
pour it into something else
can they zoom in from that angled okay
oh man we ain't getting no bags
we use uh Elgato stuff we didn't get
back for that they got the name of one
of these guys
I mean you could clearly see Frameworks
so we're getting a bag for them too
we're gonna have to move off
he has absolutely no idea what we're
talking about he got a pocket anyway and
of course we have the gaming himself the
Shinobi Lord Cognito spreading everyone
listen to the Roman IOP not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear shout out to Mr batty play Shout
out to filing Duke discussing the
funeral that is E3 we will also be
discussing the dead
body's out here you know what I mean and
uh also have some funny story about
airplane bathrooms go check that out
hilarious yeah everybody shot the club
up it was hilarious yeah yeah yeah I
heard that yeah shout out these boxes
inside the Travis shout out to the last
word for something different well that's
the difference see you know the real
context see that's that way they gonna
fly by you yeah
he shot the club up in the bathroom
I bet you what I could do is put the
green screen right here and have like
something played off it looks like I'm
like doing a podcast off a building or
something I can't with this camera
that side angle Casting Couch situation
only fans yeah like I see it's late for
like it's too much let me break let me
break protocols
Robert Kelly addict fixing his joystick
oh no
anyway
it's funny it's like hold up I'm waiting
for the music to kick in I'm waiting for
10 minutes this ain't goes for streaming
there we go this thing goes for another
website yeah we got promoting that oaf
anyway shout out to them for the last
word have a man G minus come through
I've rolled deadly a little late but uh
kid gotta show some love and then for me
the game wise um Seafood y'all Seafood
are you on the NBA no for what happened
this week I mean last week oh you talk
about um XBox shout out to the Brooklyn
yeah
I just I didn't know because I didn't go
so I didn't know if you did it so don't
don't Breeze past that because see you
know what it is
first of all I would like to dress a lot
of a lot of people let's go all right
let's get you got to say this we got to
say this
very very early on because yeah you know
because we it was something we talked
about
um we talked about that in the
background and um let me try to fix the
angle of this I don't know how to
approach it so I just leave it in the
room somebody had posted something
because I guess they saw us you know
taking pictures of food and stuff like
that and where it was like uh be careful
you know uh when your trip is crowd uh
crowdfunded okay
trip is not fully crowdfunded fashion
and it was something that we did the
first time this is the first time we
ever said yo you know like donate to
what you call it because the rising cost
is absolutely nuts this part was you
know flights uh trains
um
staying uh anywhere hotel airbnbs and
for y'all that know us for years never
actually for a cent whatever you donate
whatever comes in it truly actually goes
right back in
so a lot of those uh dinners was comped
if y'all just didn't know that like if
you see it if if you if you play for the
train
that food on the train is part of your
ticket all right so a lot of you guys
probably don't you know uh go take the
train so I'm explaining to you if you
take the train it doesn't make any sense
for you to pay uh 300 on a flight if you
can pay that same 300 on the train and
have mail included so you don't have to
worry about meals shout out to a seller
yeah so that's that's part of that right
so if you saw us doing that and if you
see us uh you know taking pictures of
something whatever
we have to get there now we could be
like a lot of other podcasts and sit at
home get information from every other
source and let somebody tell us to it
tell us this information and regurgitate
it to you
or or
we can be like one of the only podcasts
that get up off our butts we have jobs
everybody here has a job so everybody
has to take off lose time from work lose
a time from family and still go to these
events right and we go to the events
because we know that the majority of you
guys can't go to these events right but
the fact there being me telling y'all
guys anybody that had a shirt or
whatever uh we was trying to do a live
show and we did the live show if any of
y'all would have been there y'all would
have been on that live show you would
have came through because I would have
said come through I don't know what
podcast is telling you guys hey come out
here and hang out with us nobody I don't
hear nobody saying that because they're
not they're not there they they they're
home again
so we're out
eight hours we're on our feet after we
get off our feet we go back to the the
hotel or whatever and uh edit videos
another eight to ten hours get some
sleep get up and do it again then go
back we're not going out there having
fun you know if if it looks like it's
fun it's fun because we're with each
other and we're doing something that we
love right
we gotta eat bro
we gotta travel we gotta sleep we're not
getting sponsors like you think oh you
talk about the narrative that oh yeah
we're living it up oh
none of these statues in here is is
funded by podcasts
none of them so so if you look over and
you're saying they they rolling in dough
podcasters don't make as much money as
you think we don't have a million
subscribers we don't we probably have
the content you probably look at the
content and say these guys are doing it
because they're my favorite and I love
them and I and I wish that love will be
spread all across the world I wish we
did have a bag I wish I didn't have to
go to work but we do everything that you
do and send in whatever I I just like
you showing up because I remember when
it was 12. but I have 400 and some
change just to be there not even a Super
Chat just to beat it makes me feel happy
and that's what made me get on the train
and do that so when you say uh watch out
for the Optics bro
I'm giving you all the pictures of
everything that we're doing and if I
take a picture of food because I know a
lot of people like food or whatever I'm
just doing that and now do a video of
what we see at the conference I don't
want you to ever think
that we will misappropriate any funds in
any way
to not bring you content and I want you
I want you and I and I put this up
against any any podcast let's go we know
go to Lord's gaming.net and you tell me
who brought you more original content
during Pax week
any and that's that that includes IGN
anybody I don't care because we were
there we put up more content and you'll
never find those interviews other than
where we got them so please it's okay
don't don't don't don't don't ever think
that we're not giving you 110 because
we're going to give you a hundred and
ten percent all the time and that's each
and every member here because each and
every member here took off from work me
and Sovereign the day we got back went
to work that night factual factual and
let me add on real quick because uh you
preaching you know because there's a lot
of pocket watching going on and at the
end of the day like you said it you
really said it messes up but a bunch I
could add on to it it's just the fact of
how hard people are really working to
bring content and how much we give
credit to our larger gaming team you
guys is my brothers you know what I'm
saying like we're working hard so when I
see the chirping you know what I'm
saying about you know oh we dudes ain't
giving it back and dudes ain't giving it
up you know what I'm saying kind of
thing or oh they bankroll this and all
that this is Blood Sweat and Tears yo
we've been doing this since 2017. right
since it was only again like King said
10 15 people in here right we're now
trying to do something special so yeah
we're gonna we're gonna ask on occasion
there's nothing wrong with that but at
the end of the day it's just like don't
get it twisted like no one is not
Mansions going on over here you know
what I'm saying mansions and there isn't
a single dollar that comes in that goes
into our pockets actually that that's
the thing to take away nobody's taking
any bag home
the PlayStation
but I was going to leave it but I was
like I'm glad I can't yeah because you
are and the only reason why that popped
up is because says again you went out
again
last week on Thursday to to what again
yeah you know you out there making
content again a lot of this stuff I do
you know I'm trying to Network I'm
trying to make things happen for IOP for
long day everything I do is is either
with the opportunity in mind for growth
and um sometimes things happen you know
where it's like okay you know what maybe
I can take off a little bit or I could
you know go to an event and again it
would shout out to Xbox shout out to
Brooklyn Nets they were doing something
really cool in the city so I'll try to
make an appearance there shout out to
everybody who pulled up buddy Rumble
right here for me uh Mr Joanna dark my
man red red information
we're out here this is on my personal
time I don't have to do that I have a
lot of things going on y'all know I got
a full-time job yeah I know I do four
podcasts five podcasts yeah I know I'm a
CEO of a website y'all know what's going
on so again put it in perspective how
hard people are working to try to do
something special so don't ever get it
confused if we once in a while asked for
assistance because this stuff is not
cheap we're doing this out of the love
but at the same time it cut stuff cost
as Psalm would tell you as we going
through taxes
yes of course so that's it
for me but yeah I'm sorry the problem is
is like the reason that I felt like it
needed to be addressed is because once
you lose the lose the narrative it's
right yeah automatically right yeah yeah
once people start believing that yeah
and the crazy part is just like
people don't realize like even even when
you take like the financial thing out
we spent almost a week
at PAX East sure that's for us too
because you know we're providing uh
hopefully getting opportunities from
being at these events but a lot of
that's for you guys to make sure you
guys see the events uh you know
firsthand we covered a lot of good indie
games and I'm sure we'll uh because I I
understand that there was like a lot of
issues when it comes to like the sound
so what I'm going to do is try to reach
out to as many of them as possible and
have a
like a more indelible
in-depth interview with some of them
because you know and you know shout out
to to some of these companies like you
know even if some of them watching I
really don't care it's like you guys got
to do better when it comes to making
sure devs is there to represent your
game
I get it Financial wise
it doesn't make a lot of sense when you
can just hire someone there
get them in there and pull it from there
but at the same time
it's like do you realize
dying like uh Dead Island 2 was there
and there wasn't a lot of information we
could have got from people on the floor
and it's just like to me when you see
something like that what's gonna end up
happening game let's say it doesn't
perform well
you could put some of the responsibility
at the team that presented it there
because that's the last big event before
the the game comes out and it's just
like that's got to do better on that man
yeah you know that was hugely
disappointing yeah yeah and it happened
with multiple games and it's just like I
understand yeah what no I was just gonna
say it's just it felt to me that they
just put babysitters at the the stations
and to make sure we don't still
I feel it was more PR than actual
developers it dependent because it was a
little bit of both like King and I there
was I you know retro Ware had had toxic
uh Crusaders there yeah beautiful four
player beautiful four player like church
you know Turtles in Time Shredder's
revenge Street Fighter uh Streets of
Rage 4 type of game
um and shout out to them for getting
their bag right apparently they had
hired a YouTuber to sort of be at the
booth either talk about the game signing
autographs and they were able to try to
sell their merch and people who filed
this YouTuber went got the merge even if
they weren't really interested in the
game just to have the opportunity to get
their picture something signed by this
YouTuber get your money but it com in my
estimation and Kings as well because we
went to the booth multiple times trying
to get an interview wow we couldn't get
it done because the the the YouTubers
time and that time to sell
over usurped any sort of media
considerations and four times we tried
to get put this put a spotlight on this
game and it did it couldn't happen so
like I said there were things
logistically that I was like uh I'm not
feeling this like you know
but again I I can't begrudge people
getting the bag either I understand as
well right so it's it's a balance that I
think again when people are looking at
the stuff that we put out you don't
you're not there you're not going to
understand it you're gonna know it to
that granular level of what's happening
on the show floor but
it's not easy it's not easy to get the
content it was less easy this year than
it has been in past years it was it was
tough we're gonna go through that on
dead E3 stuff yeah yeah yeah because as
it turns out these might be the shows to
go to
good enough to point out that in terms
of sound I saw a lot of people saying yo
why didn't you guys see this let me
explain to you how like covering it
works it's not it's not all just one
like we record multiple interviews now
the problem was is one GoPro was set for
a directional one GoPro was set for the
actual mics that we had uh set up now
imagine when you're recording something
like you're recording your phone you're
it's a directional mic it's gonna pick
up anything in front of it so when we
were starting these interviews and it's
setting on them you hear the first 10 50
seconds sounds perfectly fine it'll be a
little bit better but the moment it's
switched to the gameplay I'm not looking
at the people doing the interview
anymore and the problem was is when we
went to look before you know because how
I would do it it's like you two or three
interviews we look at right then we see
what the audio is then we go from there
and explain the situation as to why we
couldn't look at it to catch it yeah
yeah the first 20 30 seconds it sounds
fine so I got so much stuff I'm moving
on to the next video but after that 10
second video when they're going to the
gameplay now it doesn't sound fine but
there's nothing you can do because we
didn't watch the whole thing and I and
look how it goes we do a couple
interviews we go to this place called a
Press Room uh first off the internet
that was horrible oh let's talk about it
how much haunted we're covering we have
three teams doing stuff I don't have
time to watch like three hours constant
I gotta put it I gotta name it put it on
a hard drive and save it for the hotel
because their hotel was vastly better
but that was right up to the um
that it was it was it was horrible like
the audio was it was broken
it was too late at that point but the
good thing is you know we we know what's
wrong now I know we've said that before
but we know what's wrong it's always new
stuff if you look at it and I can
encapsulate it easier because we found
it out because of me first and then um
he's in the chat saying it all comes out
of proper equipment we have we have the
proper standard stuff equipment but the
problem is is the GoPro in our equipment
wasn't working together correctly we
fixed it it's an input device that we
needed on past GoPros we updated it and
we have the media holder the media
holder doesn't need the adapter any
longer right now so it's just a little
short of it is that we upgraded our
equipment to give better production
right in the process of updating that
set equipment they took away an option
that we used to use that they were
invisible necessary right there was an
adapter that's necessary the newer ones
you don't need it but there was no
information given out regarding this in
terms of our setup and that's what set
us back so we put we are again investing
back into the podcast everything you
guys do we invest back we do something
new and then and then we gotta call out
packs a little bit is that we go to the
media room and that like the usually in
the first day we can catch anything we
go to the meeting I can't even pull up
Twitter on their internet yeah we had to
jump off yeah the Wi-Fi just to see
stuff on our phone
last year it wasn't that bad but I said
it was really good this year it was
really bad yeah
it breaks off hard got to tell you attic
I'm sorry
there was an interview the one I did a
Larry Schiff uh there was the mage of
the uh Saga or whatever that was called
those was done with the proper setup if
you listen to it because we caught we
caught Kings on the second day yeah
that the first team Coggin them was
doing it either as well if you look at
those videos that's how it's supposed to
sound but sadly when you split and
you're doing multiple things at the same
time it's hard to catch something yeah
as much information because we have a
list of people that we supposed to see
in that date and then after we go
through that list if we have any down
time
you saw that game over there let's go
get that come get it yeah right and then
you gotta Bulldog your way in and this
is where the problems comes in because
if there's no Dev on site there's no uh
PR dude on site there's no CEO on site
and it's just Booth holder
yeah I can't Bulldog no interview in
fact you can't and when I say a bulldog
interview you go over there you say yo
listen I'm from such and such such show
your credentials show your media your
media badge it's supposed to give you
presidents over everything right and
then you say yo listen I got five
minutes really quickly I can run you
through this interview we can talk about
your game I just want to get some light
on your game so I can send it to the
guys at the website now
lordsofgaming.net needs this information
so they can work facts we have writers
waiting for something to hit the Discord
to say yo this is up right now go poll
list attach this to your to your um your
video to you to your um content they
will watch the video gather the
information do their synapses then
attach that video to their to the
website and send it up so we have
multiple layers working in conjunction
with each other if anything in that
chain is broken it messes up everything
along the lines so yeah no absolutely so
again you know last thing I said because
I don't want to go too long because
Tommy Tony Grasso says move on this is
unnecessary
shout out to Tony glasson that don't
care about nothing but um look at the
end of the day last thing I want to say
is that this is what I learned the best
lesson I learned from attic our very
first packs that was um that the one you
guys didn't go to but um
basically it was a game I don't know
what it was a PC game it looked hot I
covered it and I'm trying to do a live
on it the video was so pixelated audio
was so bad and it was such a good
interview that I did with this developer
and I'm like I'm just deleting this
right and addict told me pulled me to
the side and said brother no put that up
I'm like this is atrocious I can't this
does not represent the quality that
we're used to putting out like I can't
he's like no Cog put it up cause someone
somewhere is going to want that
information regardless because he said
you got access I said all right
begrudgingly that was one of the first
videos that actually popped for us so to
speak it was like a 10K the first time
we ever got a 10K anything and the video
was a pixelated best and people were
like yo we don't we can't see what's
going on but yo this game is one of the
hottest I forgot today but it was that
something and that's why I learned the
lesson death guarded
that Garden made it pop
it was made by the people who made um
dead by daylight right and that's why I
learned as much as my heart was broken
as much as our heart was broken with a
lot of content that we put up this time
that the sound was you know I mean it
was iffy we still got to put it up you
know what I'm saying and it we're still
learning from those situations and that
again you take the L move on and adjust
but that's all I got to say anyway I
just got one thing to say I didn't
really talk about like you know the the
pocket watching thing I just want you
guys you know the people realize too
like
the thing I didn't like about is like
even if we was paying for that stuff I
felt like people expected us to eat a
Burger King like it was like you want to
get technical
what we raised helped but it didn't even
cover probably 60 of the trip uh you
know the rest came out of uh Lord's
Pockets so I feel you I I do
I I do like that people were saying it
in a form of you don't want this to get
twisted they weren't saying it
disrespectfully yeah yeah I agree so I
just I just wanted people to know that
um we respect that dollar every but I I
respect your views right I respect you
watching but I don't want you to think
that we will not respect your dollar
because we respect you know 100
appreciate it appreciate it we're gonna
keep it speaking of dollars what up Gene
what's up in the building what's up
what's up but yeah we're gonna move
forward but other than that like I said
um Seafood rocking that on Midnight Sun
still continuing and of course Seafood
still didn't get the game pass yet
what's up
oh so so it just got to Xbox yeah yeah
yeah but it ain't in Game Pass no it's
not yeah yeah oh man yeah I guess I
gotta wait
how much is it I can't be having this
video though he got the paper I was
listening
every resident evil the problem with
your gay pastors
the problem with you gave past dudes
he said nah don't don't send a 40 game
set me to 70.
damn game pass guys yo yo listen I I
needed it in my life but I thought it
was coming to Game Pass
always what a rental service you don't
want to paint it there you go so what
don't shame
you think that certain people are
getting a little ridiculous it's the
Game Pass thing but I don't think
they're gonna buy you regardless you
know when there's something that King
wants oh yeah
what I'm saying is like a lot because I
see this like stigma that like Xbox
people don't buy games okay
games to go to Game Pass chances are
they weren't gonna buy that anyway yeah
that's right 10 since they wasn't going
to get a PlayStation VR anyway moving on
yeah you've seen a lot of devs say that
now people know about my company that's
right of the service like who did that
for you for sure so look other than that
um and the last one uh velara emails are
going out check your inbox anybody
ordered yes but Larry emails are going
out you're getting that confidence you
absolutely amazing show you know got a
chance to beat those guys awesome guys
hello bring me my pillow
chill you can't ask her to do that like
that yeah
could you pass me my pillow
you get it you should get it right there
especially not at that angle yeah dude
I'll put that out there you get that IOP
official joint coming through but uh
look we're gonna move on it is that time
of the month I will get um take care of
you after this song we'll take care of
super chat if you don't yeah of course
cool cool cool so you already know what
it is that log that that lawyer gaming
that was doing that thing at PAX East
here we got some of the best coverage
I've seen nobody was outside but the
Lord's outside we were there anyway
shout out to the Scribe shout out to
everybody who put it down man it was
really fun this award is always fun
because it's very competitive we have a
great team and I do want to shout the
entire team first because um we
officially have done half of the total
traffic we've done last year in our
first three months this year put it
together put it together doing it doing
it independent y'all independent on the
scene you already know what it is but I
mean it's not signed to any major
factual independent you know what I'm
saying so yes move to the team they
absolutely killing it and yes that time
of the month man we got to celebrate a
scribe who went Above and Beyond in the
month of March we affectionately call
him the magic man because he's so better
oh God
I don't like that I don't like that egg
yo you know what I like that angle more
now all right they don't need to know we
have legs man
anyway the magic man
now I feel better yeah
it's big on the post of the culture
always knowing what's going on the NBC
Japanese scene VR not only do we meet
this Lord at Pax you know what I'm
saying he actually you know what I'm
saying he's at a lot of events New York
game awards all that stuff always exudes
professionalism and even helped a fellow
scribe get to his first packs Eastman
yes and that is beyond love man this is
he's one of the backbones in his he's
probably the Kareem Abdul-Jabbar this
award at this point
but we gotta give it yeah yeah
sir
[Music]
uh maybe I'm like the Tom gugliata um
what's up brother congratulations
you know what just uh just still
recovering from packs and all the work
we did uh everyone check it out Lords of
gaming.net yeah there's a lot of a lot
of new games coming out a lot of cool
stuff it's gonna be a great year for
games
that's it that's all you guys
some games that we that we had to unsee
solve while we're while we're together
here when can we actually talk about it
oh no it is up in the air
great yeah our favorite interviews we
did at Pax and the audio quality is
fantastic we can't talk about it because
the game doesn't exist yet apparently
yeah yeah you guys are gonna love it
when you when you uh see the interview
the game is really cool it's nice yeah
we will get that straight now what's up
the NBA dudes definitely NBA dudes we
totally played a valve yeah
I'm gonna really take a minute and Shout
you guys out because you guys don't
realize like that those kind of numbers
is easier to go back to Bethesda be like
yo people care about our opinion on
redfall and get more coverage in the
future yeah for sure for sure I just
want to let I mean um Gene like though
as far as like what else as far as your
standouts yeah uh
um the Mage Seeker was really cool so
there's a game in game pass at least it
wasn't game that's called moonlighter
yeah uh it's fantastic uh Management's
10 and uh roguelike they're gonna remove
the roguelike elements and management
some elements and a straight up action
adventure game with a ton of combat
mechanics the Mage Seeker is a new game
from that team set in the League of
Legends Universe I don't know anything
about League of Legends I don't play
League of Legends I thought this was the
coolest game the combat's Fantastic the
art is fantastic it's coming out on
April 18th I think it's uh 30 or 40
dollars for the digital copy it it looks
really cool and I got to play it for
about half an hour there's a video and
an article up and I sat with the CEO of
the company uh it was it was a lot of
fun that was my favorite game uh Russell
Quest is really cool I thought it was
very fun had the two wrestling games
were next to each other and they were
battling each other out yeah it was so
funny
yeah and and uh on your redfall coverage
you that's a great video the interview
you guys did the developer was talking
about everything that they went through
during the pandemic while making this
game and it makes like I had this moment
where
um it it sometimes it feels like a
miracle that these things happen you
know and it's and it's it's really easy
to beat up on games and say it's not
good it's an assist of that and then the
things that they had to go through uh
when they make that game and and they're
not even from California where the
wildfires were during the pandemic and a
lot of people were like you know living
in hotels or living in their cars during
the pandemic yes uh and taking their
families and children and also watching
the double fine documentary and see
everything everyone went through during
the pandemic having him say that to you
guys it was like oh my God it's a
miracle that any of these games are any
good whatsoever in fact shout out to
Harvey Smith yeah that touch of Soul
because we forget we forget the human
element and what he said that I was like
wow it took a lot for you guys to get
this game out so yeah salute to them and
yeah good point man the human element is
so important brother continue to keep
doing what you're doing your mainstay I
always love working with you and uh yeah
man looking forward to the next one man
oh as always man the Magic Man Lord G
man much love brother before you go
what's happening oh Gene just remember
who did that
who gave you that magic man name that
has stuck yeah I love this guy I swear
to God I I
um Gene Above All Above everything else
Gene is a giver
he is a very nice person a very gent he
has a general big heart right and um I'm
gonna get him from Crocs
that's gonna be my gift to you I think I
think that's gonna probably be at Pax
West or something like that but I got
some Crocs coming for you bro I'm
definitely still in the new New Balance
era of my uh Footwear yeah
I shot mine in the face stay there she's
good
much love brother thank you brother I
gotta see you no doubt no doubt what's
up
oh it doesn't make sense that to me
anyway
um yeah so and uh secondary Lord net
award in honor of you know someone's
kind of like a nurture of a talent this
is for my a great editorial team near
the lifeblood of the site you know the
unsung heroes they do all the Dirty Work
the teaching you know the editing all
that good stuff and then we have one
editor you know that not only wise they
got a calming influence always behind
the scenes and he's kind of the epitome
of like consistency and reliability he's
an exceptional writer himself always has
Stellar reviews guides recruiting
teaching
yo this this guy he's something else man
so we probably present the winner of the
Lord dizzy lock net editor of the month
award to the editor-in-chief of Lords of
gaming.net Lord way heck AKA Lord mock
move my man so he couldn't make it but
he dropped some bars for us so I'm gonna
let y'all rock out for a second
chief of Lords of gaming do you want to
give my regards to Lord Cognito Lord
Sovereign Lord King addict I'm kidding
addicts also the Lord as well no
seriously I just want to say thank you
for voting for me edit of the month to
all the writers uh we've come so long
for lognet and I'm extremely proud of
the team of what we're building and I
actually joined lognet in November 2019
so it's been a journey and if you also
want to be part of this journey be sure
to apply for loads of gaming we'll get
you set up and hopefully you'll be part
of our journey as well thank you so much
again see you in the next one
so much love for you man you you're your
asset to the team so salute to your
brother speak to Saul will get you taken
care of this story bro oh yeah yeah
already that that's already done all
right so I just need jeans
yes take care of business hold on a
second all right I got this last name
yo check this out my wife texted me
right all right somebody got these
somebody's not muted somebody not muted
yeah yo so my my wife text me right and
she goes yo it's somebody breathing
who's breathing like that I'm like I'm
downstairs I don't know that's probably
Dante watching the video upstairs she
goes no it was on the show so that's
that's why you heard it right there
right so I muted I'm like what the hell
it's the long neck joint you know
[Music]
and she's like you got to stop it if
something's happening
ain't doing nothing you should have been
like well geez I can't breathe
no it's not yo it sounds mad ominous if
somebody's busy it's the power dizzy
hold on
yeah that's this
Spirit right there
all right cool let me get these super
chats all right we have Robert kellett
five dollar Super Chat oh lord it's
morning after the death of sega's Blue
Rat
he had a tragic and like poor little to
me yesterday yeah I don't know I guess
this is a uh an April Fool's joke or
whatever I don't know if it's a real
thing I I didn't see it but apparently
there's a game out on Steve called the
death of Sonic the Hedgehog
that's wild that's wild yeah so I didn't
check to see how real it is I mean if
you know people go real you know they go
in depth with these April Fool's jokes
then we got Ed ROM ten dollars if we
chat I had an opportunity to meet the
lawyers in person that packs East last
Friday like I mentioned you guys are the
best part of my Sundays and my favorite
podcast this is Eddie I hope y'all
remember me no doubt yes I remember
Eddie I think Eddie came up and he he
was with his wife and he's like yeah he
waited after we finished the interview
and he was just like yo um honey tell
him tell him what what I tell you I said
that he tells her Don't You Buck up on
me
that's different yeah that's awesome
yeah always again like we said pull up
man pull up just say what's up
we got Nintendo Taco five dollar Super
Chat weekly reminder that breath of the
wild and and in extension tears of the
kingdom are more Innovative than any
game Sony and Xbox have made in their
entire existence [__] I'm on your neck
he ain't gonna like me when it's my
segment
here you go
[Music]
then we have THX 1138 two dollars for
chat first thing I do is hit the like
button let's go salute salute thank you
appreciate you then we got a little
Metroid member for one year two dollars
to protect Cog already disrespected
Nintendo shocking
like I literally the one that came up
with switch company
I believe one of the ambassadors
he mad he mad that you missed tears of
the kingdom in the intro that's what he
meant yeah
so then we got Robert Kelly so we
letting DLC win game of the year
foreign
first of all we can all say that God of
War was using the same assets bro let's
just see first because I think you
didn't see the things
it was probably the same Assets in this
DLC there so you can take a look at how
the shows
got my email saying delivery for UK
purchases will be arriving around April
15th no doubt yes yo listen um just real
quick on the pillows they're shipping
now if anybody was holding out saying oh
yo I don't know yet I want to know when
they start shipping they're shipping out
go to the store the the link is in the
description
go get a pillow trust anybody that was
on this floor that saw us rocking with
him yeah yeah we were snatching people
up like yo check out the pillow check
out the pillow yeah I know you like Tech
and I know you like a Dragon Ball but
check out the pillow the lottery
Champion as well
nobody gave me his social media yet I
need to follow that dude
then we have uh Robert Keller two
dollars in the chat having fun
protecting those ballistics and re4
protecting the ballistics
I mean what do you mean like you're
saving your ammo
played Resident Evil
I mean Resident Evil 4 is really about
you just shooting people in the kneecaps
and kicking them and doing stuff that's
really what it is uh let me got Zip Zip
Davis two dollars for chat the Lords are
back can we get an oh wait check hey you
got it already
no we haven't intend on the otaku five
dollar Super Chat it's good to see Sega
finally did the right thing and killed
Sonic yo
with the Dreamcast
okay all right we got Hollywood rules
remember for 14 months Lord silver
welcome back my NYC cousins thank you
for the great coverage best podcast on
YouTube happy Sunday Brothers respect
thank you brother Peace Love
there we go Robert Kelly again two
dollars addicts big addicts fixing his
joystick oh no
then we got ninja buckles two dollars
Super Chat please call out that Quantum
break nonsense yes Quantum break and
Xbox first party title leaving Game Pass
uh I guess interesting situation yes yes
when they sell the publishing rights to
Quantum break back to remedy though if
that's the case yeah then that would
make sense that would make sense
actually I think that was the other game
they make
Alan Wake I think they saw that back
then we got Tom from Toonami five dollar
Super Chat
oh it was that Scary Movie 2 type of
ghost situation talk about addict's new
home and all the ghosts that they had oh
yeah and then we got free on Kelly five
dollar Super Chat good morning Lords
addict you six five king
that's all that's tall
free R Kelly new Avatar you see his
Avatar with you what's going on let me
see it I told you what it is it's the
pink sorrow Oh man that's crazy that's
crazy cow's doing the most
hotel room let's go
hold on a second that we had why did you
ever tell us you were that tall hey gang
it's over for Microsoft Sony buying
Square Enix
you don't need the wife first she giving
that up for free yeah yeah
you're wasting money
she ain't even cheating she ain't doing
nothing so she loyal with the hope she
she got hope for you about to you about
to cash in y'all lying yeah
go spend that money on those places
where nobody like you
we have Nintendo Taco two dollars shout
out to Maddie for understanding
greatness yes Maddie's takes on uh tears
of the kingdom are quite different to
Cox
I like what people got to feel it
Justified for their picks
that guy didn't
agree logic Aries five dollars for chat
smoking on that E3 pack tonight
yo y'all gonna like the folks then we
got Jeff Keeley had to spin the block on
them tough
wow wow
oh absolute Lord shout out to you sir
project Aries and we got Holly first of
all that's highly disrespectful
[Laughter]
as soon as we start talking about that I
think they're leading to what I was
thinking
and we got Hollywood rules member for
one year five dollars chat ready for
King ready for Kings when snitching goes
wrong segment
Congress said what about you though
thank you so much for covering screw the
haters thank you thank you
and we got Kate Johnson member for 14
months Lord bronze tell them stop pocket
watching appreciate your loss for doing
the hard work for the round thank you
thank you
appreciate that salute then we got time
from Toonami remember for one year
welcome oh let's put the crest in the
chat for Tom from Toonami well Lord
bronze appreciate you brother bronze
innocent okay
then we got lydian Master remember for
four months Lord silver I agree with
King the Lord's paxis coverage was
Second To None I love what you guys do
that's why I show up every week ILP
forever y'all thank you so much love
thank you appreciate that thank you
then we got Hollywood rules again
remember for one year five dollar Super
Chat Cog salute to you and my beloved
Brooklyn Nets that Nets console was fire
yeah man I was trying to win that yeah
yeah they look nice
you send me this and you thought I was
supposed to fall back and say this was
DLC no you love it we get to it oh okay
[Music]
wow wow let's get to it keep going y'all
cause this is wow
yeah you guys are always super
transparent thank you for what you guys
do no doubt they appreciate that and we
have Clayton Saint sire five uh five
five dollars and fifty cents he thought
it was another currency
I love the Lords but not that Casting
Couch energy addict salute y'all it's
hard work you gotta add to the pop for
the next event
look man you know feeling the angle
what's funny is like you know I had to
do another career because I don't know
talk about your side hustles man
whoa time
[Laughter]
well yeah while it rain now continue
it's yuck
and we have Ariel night [__] on the
stupid chat normally I just look but
y'all doing a good job homie sometimes
it's all for the best so that nothing
goes wrong for the next one thank you
brother that's right Nick never yield
that's never yield yes everyone oh
salute to the home yo I think these are
one year anniversary of never you I
believe you're celebrating that salute
to you brother salute to him man yeah
super proud of you man salute everybody
that's what's up then we have remedy
live five pound Super Chat people
slandering the quality of the packs
video should go try it for themselves
first thank you IOP for the footage and
all you did at Pax
I I don't I don't want people thinking
just like it was it was constructive
criticism no one was mad disrespectful
right real yeah that that criticism was
well valid and we'll do better yeah
and we've got 108 dragons TV five dollar
Super Chat missed you over there brother
yeah yeah it takes work no play play
y'all did y'all did an awesome job stay
the course always addict on point
absolutely shout out to 108 dragon go
check out his show Dragon's Den
yesterday he did Saturday he talks about
uh the racist comments from Square Enix
please go check that out so you can see
what he's talking about yeah also
um mystery brother he he definitely
would have helped us
identify issues quicker because yeah
for sure
remember for one year
got my popcorn and ready for King to go
off and watch [__] try to damage control
psvr
happy Sunday Lord yo that was wow funny
absolutely getting you better for you
guys better oh much better oh yeah
[Music]
no wide camera angles anymore
then we got the homie Place 4K Super
Chat addict got that place 4k camera
angle fire
can you know what to say baby
thank you thank you very much
Blaze man salute to the homie then we
got General back member for two years
shout out to Joe Mackey gifted five IOP
memberships thank you brother appreciate
it thank you appreciate the videos I see
you always puts up the video right
before we go live oh we're starting to
keep it respectful in the realm oh geez
Bay Area salute yes sir yes sir then we
got Michael Askew Jr remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat salute from
the Lord from Lord skew great month of
content thank you brother appreciate you
I love you stop spamming me in your your
console war post cause he'd be beefing
with dudes be like yeah they did this
I'm like bro
yo
shout out to skew he's passionate good
dude good dude
then we got a shark in a chair for 100.
ridiculous I love that you acknowledge
your helpers and staff just uh just a
little just something to help thank you
appreciate you brother but nobody's a
helper or nobody stabbed everybody is
team
for sure for you guys
oh my God
I got a new apartment new place do house
continue
then we haven't decorated sale remember
for 16 months Lord gold it's another
great day with the Lords let's get the
likes up yeah look at the likes up
and it got that hot cam girl angle I'm
done
all they need is ready he got that POV
we got
them
you got to get his face out of there
like that we're gonna have to get some
um Iron Lord podcast V-neck shirts
like the problem is is like my monitors
prevent me from doing stuff with like my
uh
[Music]
tears of the kingdom is DLC keep it a
stack but that's forgiven because it's
Zelda Ragnarok was a slap to the face
because they emasculated crater oh my
God
then we got heartbeat city five dollars
hanging out with the crew last weekend
in the game show that in a game show
that hasn't been canceled
not yet across our fingers
yeah that's what I was about to say
Harvey be out in these streets man yeah
I got you see I know hearty real because
I've seen him yeah
brother we're gonna make it right in the
room and do it the right yes
sorry I jacked your uh jacket that was
my back
but you know but argue you go my only
fans I'm that that's what that's what I
mean
um
the name of that video is hoggy me
I did give me a chair
all right
[Laughter]
yeah Lord make sure two dollars
there we got Lord Manchester or two
dollars to protect [__] my condolences
rest in peace Sonics
then we got fonze gaming remember 22
months Lord bronzer hold me to brother
just want to send some love to my
brothers from another mother love you
Lords keep doing your thing appreciate
you brother appreciate you fox good to
see you brother always sir
then we got tsws gaming five dollar
Super Chat hope everyone is having a
good day so far can't wait to get Lord
Cognito on behind them sticks shout out
to the Lords and chat we support out of
love thank you appreciate it went down
it's going down we finally ironed out of
Time It's Going Down Saloon to him Solo
in the crew yeah it's a solo yeah I
gotta talk to solo too oh yeah oh he got
you down too somewhere we gotta figure
it out this is the best it's gonna get
this is the best okay
so how bad do you want this roll
yeah
we could do this the easy way
how far behind are you on rent do you
say
so they cut your lights off
[Laughter]
equals con bad
time
or attic Casting Couch we got Lawrence
Davenport five dollar super chat if
Microsoft buys Square Enix we might get
black characters in this game
they got no choice after that
we moving on we're moving on yo you know
they mad though because he's like yo we
did a black character for smoking and
game came out
someone said someone put in there uh
someone said help me stop uh Step at it
yo whoa yo we got out of pocket
wow
[Laughter]
Echelon seven member for 26 months Lord
Silva peace to the Lord thank you so
much
salute no doubt we got Michael Askew Jr
once again five dollar Super Chat I had
to get [__] back for pushing that weight
with that way powder in the streets
salute to the gym crew all fans GG go
get that you know what I'm saying get
that little boost we should have brought
it we should have bought that for the
trip man y'all here yeah coffee come on
now green tea I'm Puerto Rican I can't
stop the coffee I love the I love the
focused
I needed that Focus bro oh that was it
we're caught up finally thank you guys
appreciate y'all no doubtful to the
realm no poke last week
um one patreon question
okay brother I'm gonna butcher your name
I believe you're from Iceland
uh people always talk about how Kojima
will use Ms cloud in his next game have
the Lord thought about it working about
his working with the AI team how do we
feel about that
um I think that's a smart idea in using
that how he's going to use it I'm pretty
sure he's going to be Innovative and how
he uses it I don't know if he uses the
AI to answer in unique different ways
with in conjunction of the cloud so you
might get a game that is totally unique
to you at that moment we we don't know
how he's going to craft this game but if
he goes in that area with it it may be
an Ever evolving game well as much as
I don't particularly like kojima's games
and I think he's over uh over hyped a
little bit dude's got a big name and if
Microsoft can do anything with him they
better do it no doubts uh Kojima with AI
possibly I think I mean whatever he does
with that team it's probably something
that we're not even thinking about and
that's just the way kojimo thinks like
you know we could say whatever we want
to say about you know him you know just
over
over complicating simple Concepts and
making it seem like it's like oh my God
but the man you can't really deny the
mass trajectory you can't glad you can
so for me if there's anybody who could
look at cloud and its capabilities and
try to do something different with it
that we haven't seen it's him so the AI
stuff seems interesting because again
when we talked about Cloud right the
funny thing is with Cloud the streaming
aspect of cloud is it's kind of look
like the lowest hanging fruit like oh I
can stream my games over the cloud
that's the easiest part quote unquote
easiest
um it's the other stuff they talked
about like
you know a persistent world that has
thousands of people and whatever NPCs
and again AI that allows it to feel more
realistic and and and and vast right
there's a lot of stuff that we don't
even know can be done in the cloud and I
think I always think back to what they
talked about with Crackdown three and
the possibilities with that right
um now this is a dude that I think he's
gonna try and he may fall fat on his
face you know because sometimes the tech
may not be there for what he really
wants to do we'll see you know um
you can actually say that Crackdown was
a victim cloud like kind of and the sad
part is I I really feel like Crackdown
didn't get the Justice it deserved they
spent so long trying to solve that PVP
aspect that destructive destroy
everything aspect that
if they would have took that time into
investing into the single player and
give a good co-op sandbox area I feel
like we would be hearing news of a
Crackdown four at this point and
Crackdown three was fun three was
fantastic it was fun I have a video of
me doing because I I was like max level
and I have a video of me trolling kid's
move for like 10 minutes because because
like anything he did I could do better
right oh my God
it was idiots
what's funny is like I had the I had the
gauntlets that will like link to the
cars so if he was if he jumped in a car
to get away from me I would literally
reach my hand out it just it just yanked
his car over and you'd be in the car and
I would throw him in the car
messy messy yeah I don't have too much
to add um
I I will say I think Kojima is very
Innovative and to see him with Cutting
Edge technology excites me yes he could
be out of the box sometimes but look
this is what attracts people to this
game he does a Lot of Things Different
Western sensibilities also him with AI
would be interesting what do you do yeah
see what he calls but I actually am more
excited about the cloud aspect I want to
see if someone actually could utilize
cloud in gaming in a unique way besides
just server infrastructure and lobbies
and like I want to see Layla lay low
that yeah I think he he can because all
right let's let's be real death
stranding
for what it is it was Innovative as far
as having a community help you build
structures and do things right so you
can see the Game grow I just think he
had it on the wrong platform right now
that he's on the right platforms
think think big think big
um y'all know what goes after think big
but um I just think that he did uh the
real dudes reached over at him was like
we saw what you did that was cute over
there but over here you're able to do
this and then he was like yo I can do
this with AI
imagine what he can do I mean I know
that guys he's a complete out of the box
thinking we need more we need that in
the industry and like I said we do know
that he had to deal with before stadia
folded he had to deal with them so now
Microsoft so sometimes thank God they
fold it right you know so I'm assuming
but anyway we go you're best we're gonna
move on we're gonna move on so look at
this top guys
real quick um you know I you guys just
heard us answer a question you know if
you guys want to do that every week we
have a patreon five dollars here unless
you ask any of our shows questions
that's not a good look for the crew no
they want to see that content I put back
there no no attic you need to give all
the content for free nah well uh King is
reacting to attack on Titan right now
I'm reacting to my hero Academia and I
actually have a request from someone's
house after I finish that what you did
before
uh I did uh
chainsaw man which is great interesting
I I saw like a crazy chainsaw man
um cosplay Eddie you saw that right two
of them yeah I said oh attic I'm talking
to attic minding my business attic look
chainsaw man the dude turning around was
like that's damn right
so I think because I see a couple of you
people but I've been messaging me on
Twitter with ideas they want calls to
react to real ideas like metal music
they want called to react I could
actually do that I could actually figure
out some time I actually yeah I want Cog
to listen to master puppets oh Lord
[Music]
Chicago he'll play some stuff when I was
out there and I was like all right I
could get there I was crying to be Tony
Polacco yeah I was clown to be because
musical selections was it hard yo you
know what we should do we should get
with Jason
Ronaldo yeah and have them come up with
five songs
needs to listen to yes I think that'll
be a good segment yeah that'd be dope
that'd be dope I could do something
down in the chat shout out to spitty
Smith obviously you're in a minute
saying that patreon content is fire I
agree No Doubt yeah so uh right now
we're doing that I actually what I'm
going to do I have something really
special plan for the patreon but I'm
still working with the people to get it
taken care of and uh Saul was going to
react to anime fights that I choose
put anime fights that you would like to
see saw react to I'm kind of curious put
in there anime fights tag tag iron Lords
podcast so I can find it later and uh
you know we'll see I'll look at them by
myself because we can't have solve
reactor that's like some technical stuff
going on
he talked about Nine Inch Nails
this is Green Day let's go let's go what
y'all know about that Green Day When I
Come Around yeah
since he made awards for him saying
Green Day's metal
um
You're Gonna Wanna Get to on that
patreon because uh he he's going to be
reacting to offspring gotta keep them
separated
I know all the hard structure it's going
to be structured how it is now where the
uh one tier lets you re uh lets you see
the reactions the one tier lets you give
us react uh stuff to react to DJ
pistol Slipknot I wouldn't even consider
slip not like true metal that's not
metal but it is more on Parable metal is
than the than the numbers
I thought that was when I come around
Crackdown three was only gimped because
epic bought the cloud engine team they
that were making that they were making
it and told them they couldn't use the
tech in the game yeah that's that that's
ridiculous yeah the behind the scenes on
that game was crazy
um then we got excuses though
darn thread with the 106 seconds
[__] sex coins
I'm surprised you do my uh stage name
did it then it proceeds with attic is a
big dude
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
yeah okay
what happens when you out here exciting
The Crowd Oh my God you're gonna get
your own please play with my joystick
yeah
just real quick before I move on yo have
y'all seen I know you put put these up
[__] but the two latest Tekken
characters yes
the Leroy Jenkins bro why he look like
King and why he got do we got the big
Frenchie Rose yes like I'm like this is
literally someone watch King it was like
yo we gonna put him in can we see the
king of drip or something like the Grand
Master of drip drip yo he is the dopest
I was like yo I ain't gonna lie though I
was like yo and he he's the only
character that looks like you know the
um what's the guy in um uh virtual fight
is uh Akira
yeah
he does his style that's his style
that Wayne chunks it out that's his
style very brutal very up close it's
dope I love it
yeah that joke is crazy oh
absolutely it look like they do it
because because I'm a family line yeah
so yeah all right all right oh now it's
time
night Fridays bro yeah yeah I think the
people the people are calling for fight
nights
man they in we back we back baby I'm
taking my uh my 2-1 Victory I don't care
about that
and I'm writing and I'm writing into the
sunset and it's like I'm not gonna be
the box
you'll never see me in a scenario where
that could be tooken for me
I'm gonna take it from you oh we good
are we are we good yes sir oh wait
actually we got Robert Kelly take
something from you we never go start the
show's wifey was like you're gonna
finish early today
we have no gas it's gonna be longer you
know what it's gonna be seven hours we
got Robert Kelly Two Dollars Super Chat
Last of Us PC truly isn't a premium
product fam now the true Shane the devil
I'll be waiting for the update son yeah
what's the master race energy are we
good all right let's get this popping um
I'm up so it's double feature because
the Lords are away we got a lot of stuff
to talk about so the first um obviously
E3 E3 canceled so um shout out to repot
they announced that uh E3 2023 will not
take place as scheduled this June with
both the physical and digital events
cancel alongside the esa both parties
will re-evaluate the future of e3 it
looks like there was an additional
statement there was a difficult this is
by the um the esa difficult decision
because of all the effort and all our
partners put towards making this great
event happen but we had to do what's
right for the industry and what's right
for E3 that was repop Global VP on Kyle
Marston fish we appreciate and
understand that interested companies
wouldn't have playable demos ready and
that resourcing resourcing challenges
made being at E3 this summer an obstacle
they couldn't overcome for those who did
commit to E3 2023 we're sorry we can't
put on a showcase you deserve and that
you've come to expect from read pops
event experiences so yeah this was going
around this week and we started to hear
the Rumblings prior that Publishers were
either pulling out we saw like Sega we
saw tencent and prior to that we saw you
know I felt like the writing was all the
war so now that the news is how are we
feeling Lord's E3 looks like gun and
done for good attic where you at
I don't think it's done for good I do
think that it took a huge hit this year
that I would say it's a good 50 50. you
know uh I do think that
the pandemic had a lot going into this
and people and the people they would
normally go to probably don't have
nothing to show like as far as like an
actual demo I do think there is a thing
as people are learning they can actually
throw their own events and not really
worry about you know paying people for a
kind of event like that I think it comes
down to it's like you know
I would be like I said 50 50 chance that
comes back next year I think that
you know e3s took a huge hit throughout
the years and I think that when it comes
to this one this is another hit and this
is hit that they might not be able to
recover from you know and this is the
first one repop took over and they had
to cancel it yeah uh so you know it's
going to be interesting now the reason I
think there might be a 50 chance they
come back is because they are being ran
by repop not right now and repop might
feel like look we didn't even get a tip
to do it so next year we'll try harder
and we'll try to actually get the event
go and you know uh Jeff Keeley man uh he
he definitely took no time oh rub it in
their face I actually you know I I am a
man of messiness and that that but I
think I wouldn't have even done that
like it's just like man let them breathe
let them go outside and breathe like
it's like literally on like 202 they
announced E3 is canceled the 205 he's on
Twitter how about that E3 you're like
yeah he's like great reporting
Jeff is like I haven't really liked
summer
right whatever it's called Summer game
first I haven't liked it every time
they've done it I think they've done
better from previous years but they
haven't done a show to make me think
they can replace something like E3
what the hell is going on
personally to me personally
I feel like Jeff Keeley needs to show us
quality or shut up like don't die here
all the time talking smack when you
ain't made something even remotely
relevant to what E3 used to be uh and
that that's my biggest thing it's like
look like you obviously go out there and
banter that's cool but it's like to me
I'm tired of hearing things from people
and it's not just Jeff Keely it's Xbox
PlayStation Nintendo I'm tired of
hearing things how lit things are going
to be show me show me why we don't need
the E3 Jeff I hope you do I really do I
hope you do but to me you can't be
talking like that unless you've actually
done something that's on that show now
no one's going to take away from this
bad what he's achieved with the Video
Game Awards yes no one's ever going to
take that away but it's like the summer
games show feel like you still have room
to improve and to me
I don't think you should be going out
there like pretty much celebrating an
organization that's iconic as E3 sure
you have your own little squirrels with
them and I get that but it's just like I
personally feel like that was very
untasteful well that's just my opinion I
feel the effort what about real quick
before I pass it to solve um what about
again we don't know the particulars but
what if it was like real beef
like what if it was real beef
let me just give you an example remember
when it's back in the day you know
saying IOP was other places and stuff
and then it was like you'll never be as
big without us
so like like so so so let's just say
they said that to Jeff but yeah here's
the thing here's the thing when we got
to these shows that we were told we
couldn't go do we go on Twitter saying
no did we watch I was messing up
here's the thing though websites went
down in general and we didn't come out
messy like that like it's just like to
me you know and we were showing quality
products we were showing quality
podcasts we did a really well website we
had reason that we could have done some
now like I said no it's going to take
away Jeff keeley's uh you know his Video
Game Awards because I think he is the
man for the Video Game Awards but to me
until you show me that you have that
type of product when it comes to you
know uh a show such as E3 and to be able
to replace them don't go out there
talking messy you know one would think
it's like you know he sent me an email
saying summer game showing ain't
canceled
I'm sure there's a lot of people that
enjoy the summer game show that's cool
but to me I've always felt like it
wasn't hitting like E3 did and it's like
until you do something that was even
better because let's be we're here to me
Jeff Keeley ain't made a better
show than E3 when it comes to the summer
game show the in the years he's been
doing it then none of e3s because I feel
like the cards it's too spread it was
thin it is I feel like by the time I'm
getting the hype of one thing they've
already moved on to the next I feel like
in terms of quality thing he's got like
really weird like influencing thing
going on there where it's just like the
chemistry he's just trying to get a bag
from every place yeah and I feel you but
get it back from every place that you've
proved that you deserve that bad but
he's like the detriment of the
information but all right it's okay to
be the hot thing on the map on the
corner when you're the only hot thing on
the corner it's not the hot thing on the
corner it's the convenience store he
gives me convenience store vibes
right he don't give me bigots
no I'm telling you he don't give me big
restaurant Vibes right E3 is is is big
uh restaurant Vibes you're going in
there you're gonna sit down you're gonna
get a great meal you know
his joint is like more like little
Buffet stuff like little convenience
store stuff I just and we can miss those
days and don't miss news
maybe it's definitely not 100 like Fair
on the matter because what you
experience enough e3s 2016 2018 it's
going to be hard for them to compete
with that yeah but at the same time it's
like
but that's the thing I think that's the
point that he's not competing if he's
not trying to compete if you think about
why he separated from them it was that
they're thinking on what the show should
be and what him reading the tea leaves
about where the world was at was like
well this whole this humongous sort of
physical presence it doesn't make sense
anymore it needs to be digital it needs
to be Global and so in that regard he
wants it to be a larger presence overall
but the the physical part of it is never
going to compare to easily I don't think
that's his point
but but that's my thing like yeah I feel
like E3
took a huge wound when Sony left
Jeff has the ability to get these people
in the same room and have serious
conversations and until I see that I
can't really 100 get down on the games
car on the on the Summer Fest because
it's like to me
you have this year because last year we
thought oh you know E3 digital and the
year of e3 was canceled he did it here
it's like equivalent to what people say
about Xbox being an E3 when PlayStation
is not there you're the only show in
town
you got to show up or you don't show up
and to me whether or not E3 comes back
next year just depends on how well Healy
is able to capitalize on them not being
there now if he can't do it to the
degree then a lot of people would I
think they're right back next year but
if you can and he really takes his show
to the next level because of the the
absence of this other Studio then I
think you know he's got something there
but let's be real like a lot of places
they're not really part of of his summer
game Fest like it's like oh you know
we're gonna put you on the interior
we're going to put you on the schedule
Xbox is going on this day but they're
not really there physically or anything
related to that there's no branding on
that he's just like oh this is part of
the week so we snatching this branding
with us
I think it's done because what's what's
obvious to me is that
repop they're not you know they know
what they're doing in regards to putting
on a show they knew the challenges that
they faced they came out very pretty
early and you know after you know King
and I made our declarations about what
we wanted and they came out and they and
they you know they said okay this is the
type of show we're putting on these son
yeah they did
[Laughter]
when you think about it it's like so
they to me it feels like they did their
due diligence but at the end of the day
all the members of the esa the
microsofts the Sony's the Nintendos
at the end of the day they didn't want
this to happen because for whatever
reason whether it be money
considerations uh whether it be just not
being ready at this specific time and
not feeling that they need to be ready
at this specific time every single year
whatever the case may be whatever E3
used to be does not work for them
anymore and rather than out and out say
you know what we're just not doing this
anymore they kind of it feels like they
kind of kept each other on a string and
then at the end just was were honest and
we're like nah we're not doing this but
it really does feel like
like read pop tried to have those
conversations and you have to have real
conversations like hey what do y'all
want from this what is he doing sorry
yeah right it was wow yeah it was
autofocus okay I was just thrown off
continue they just assumed it was like
right here it is
[Music]
yeah so my my camera is portable
so yeah that's the thing to me it just
it just really feels like the people
that are part of the esa that are
supposed to be sort of advocating for it
don't want this and rather than be like
we just don't flat out want it for
whatever reason it just feels like those
conversations weren't honest because if
the conversations were honest we would
have known in January
it just really feels like these
conversations aren't honest which is
weird to me because now the esa is out
money that they had to put down for the
convention center right they out that
whatever they deposited is a wrap you
know they're probably not getting that
back so it just feels like look
if if there is no consideration to be
made as to how we can make this happen
where
the vast majority of it is subsidized
and by either fans or some other sort of
some other sort of uh money stream which
they don't have
no Dev no publisher is going to want to
go there and spend all this money to
show off their game for a week anymore
it's just not realistic for whatever
reason nobody wants to spend that money
and then shout out to the chat because
they're saying you know rich people keep
their money that's how they stay rich
and at the end of the day when you can
control your message when you can
control when the message comes out
and how much money you spend on it you
know once you learn that you can do that
and and the same and the end result is
the same you're not going to be wanting
to do this it's sad because the the idea
of a physical show where we all get to
spend time with each other we run to
these booths and be able to see this you
know I'm grateful that I got to go to a
press conference I'm grateful that I got
to see a crazy Nintendo Booth I'm
grateful I got to see all those things
but I don't think that's just a reality
anymore and to attic's point about Keely
I don't think Keely is ever going to
make that type of show whatever he has
locally in terms of being able to see
games and interviews and stuff like that
is still going to be relatively small in
comparison to what three ever was it's
never going to be that way and uh you
know shout out to Gene that we're at
Gene Park in the chat but we got we got
Gene magic man as well and Gene has a I
I'm gonna be a little more diplomatic
about it but it kind of feels like
there's still there's certain old school
media that get access to
reply if you're not in that Circle it's
hard to get in that Circle we will see
we will see that as media and the
Lawrence
I've gotten to the point where we're not
getting in that Circle yeah
I can Bulldog my way into that Circle
of my way into somewhere I'm not welcome
well no I mean you're welcome you just
gotta have the right ear to pull and you
know we have the right ears to pull well
the bottom line for us is that all we
care is about the content right right we
all we cares about the content you know
again other political considerations I
don't know about that I don't care about
that I'll go with that
um
hold on hold on we got a shout out to
hip-hop real quick I had to bring
protocol
my brothers love y'all and yep 3 is done
the info I received on it dog behind the
scenes was wow so nope it ain't coming
back I'm telling y'all it was maybe some
beef man hip hop when you get to me yeah
so shout out to Hip-Hop Hip-Hop that
worked oh yeah and Hip-Hop
call me yeah we got a leg bro that's on
the game man hip hop okay well last year
like let me tell you how how like
serious this click is like last year the
Lord is like you know you've never been
a video game before let's reach out and
we got like we got such a reach around
when it come to like [__]
again
saying we got a reach around indicates
that we got a happy ending
[Laughter]
when it comes to that you just got to
know people and like we do know people
but we've never had serious
conversations with like the higher end
people or that is yeah
so oh yeah you're interested you
it's like we put a lot of time and
effort into this like we would do three
to five to eight to twelve at podcasts a
week at hours a week and it's just like
sometimes it do be feeling like people
like we gotta see more what else you
want you want my kidney
well my spleen like what's going on what
else you want
it's a it's a tough sell so we'll we'll
see what it is but at the end of the day
E3 as it was or any reasonable facsimile
we might get from Jeff is never going to
resemble the original real deal that's
probably why I'm unfair to him to a
point is because like I want that like I
feel like if you spawn something in its
place I want it to be just as good if
not better now let me ask you all this
because I have this question right
if
I don't know Logistics in terms of the
size of these convention centers
whatever LA Convention Center is
considerably bigger than the Boston
Convention Center yes
because my thing is like they're still
able to put on a Pax right and it's okay
it's a smaller convention but these
small the the small Indie Studios and
and you'll get your bigger Publishers
but not really crazy like that's mostly
made up of smaller games and smaller uh
Publishers they're able to do this every
year and they're willing to do it and
they see the benefit because they
continue to do it
what if
I don't know like is there is there a
world where we can accept a smaller
scale E3 in the vein of this where
obviously the the money that they're
asking from Publishers is less the
expect maybe the expectation overall is
less but you get some of that or do you
think the the bigger Publishers with the
bigger games just rather do their own
thing
their own narrative if they own the day
whatever day they pick to talk about
their games and leave the smaller games
to these sort of conventions I guess
when it comes to me I don't for one
moment believe that Jeff can't replace
E3 in its entirety
um you know we've seen the video game
awards every year I felt like he got
better he took feedback he ended up
improving the show you know sometimes he
would go down in another area that he
was better at the year before but I will
say that the Video Game Awards is up uh
you know up trending trajectory wow so I
think it comes to this and you know not
to mention
one of the biggest things you don't have
no one to compete with if V3 doesn't
come back you don't have to worry about
you know E3 talking to EA or Ubisoft and
thought and be like yo you only have to
pay just be on the floor like so they
don't have to worry about that so it's
just he just got to worry about
improving the show and you know being
more uh you know friendly and the ways
he needs to to uh to bring in Revenue
when it comes to sponsorships and stuff
it's just I feel like Jeff does end up
making it seem more like a commercial
for stuff than an actual live show and I
think that that is my biggest criticism
I've always felt like when it comes to
trajectory on like the commercial and
how much you know sponsorship those it's
like way over here sometimes yeah but
that's that's the devil you gotta get in
bed with right to make it happen so
that's again that's the double-edged
sword now my last question is
Esa we always talk about the esa in the
context of e3 right because that's how
they make their money but the the
reality is that the esa is a lobbying
organization to protect sort of the uh
the interests of the gaming industry in
terms of policy in terms of you know in
terms of how the country views it right
and our government views it
if they can't make if E3 can't come back
do they just collapse because at the end
of the day we do need them for that
function and if that is the case and
they can't support themselves then at
the end of the day how do we advocate
for this for for this industry an
industry that at this point is is so
large that it doesn't need Advocates I
would think
you would think it doesn't need advocacy
but you can see there's still a lot of
ignorance around what gaming in the
industry is and how important and large
the industry is and especially at the
government levels when I saw some of
those memes about questioning of
tick-tock and how they're not they don't
know what the hell they're talking about
so it's a scary thing not to have an
organization be able to sort of convey
the truths about the industry and
without E3 which is their only Revenue
stream what happens to the essay yeah
that's a good question let's get kids we
gotta get his boss man so answer that
question and then also I've been silent
I know I've been there sometimes I know
that was it was a good time with a lot a
lot of discussion but yeah to solve
question you know what happened to say
but overall you know is this the final
nail in the coffin for E3 you know okay
you've been going to a few okay
I always say if you have no presence you
lose your grip right so if you're not
there don't expect to be there next year
so is this the proverbial nail in the
coffin yeah
it's funny how a lot of you guys
Champion physical
right yeah Champion physical media oh
but you also say we don't need E3
you can't be on that same page right if
if if you
Champion physical you must Champion E3
if you Champion digital you must
Champion the death of E3
the digital era
kills the physical
in the physical flesh is E3
people are at the events in the physical
we are seeing things we can touch things
we can talk to people in the physical
Jeff stands on the side of digital
Jeff stands on the side of death of E3
because he feels that he can give you
content that is fulfilling
won't take you to the next level won't
be the big things but it's sustainable
and it's digital you can sit at home you
can have the convenience of checking out
the games that you want to see over a
period of time of a week
Dime Store stuff
this is not grandioso stuff this is not
Sony out there with the flute guy this
is not big budget things this is small
budget things you will never get that
physical back again because once
somebody with money notices that they
can use a fraction of said money to get
the same result factual they will be
less likely to give up larger sums of
money the first time your boss found out
that he can have you work overtime for
not time and a half but just half a time
you got paid half time from then on
right so the first moment you able to
accept less you got less
this is what's happening now I thought
that um Reid what repop would do a Pax
event yeah on a larger scale
I thought that you have more Indies with
AAA games there being licensed from said
Indies for them tournament ways like I
thought it would be more PC like we saw
at Pax this year it's it's a trend
that's happening that I'm noticing more
that you can have these AAA games we had
Street Fighter there you had some tech
and stuff here you had stuff there but
not necessarily from Capcom
didn't need to be the name code PC
representation right so I thought they
would do that
I thought they would hold on at all
costs because knowing once your presence
is missed they forget about you now is
E3 dead yes
if it is dead I don't see it coming out
and I was holding out the same day I was
talking to somebody I was telling them I
said Jeff
and his team and everybody behind it is
pushing the conversation for E3 to be
dead you got to look at who benefits the
most at E3 leaving
he does that's why he's quick to tweet
out
game game game Fest or whatever the hell
he does is still alive we didn't really
games is still here because he's smoking
on that E3 pack so that's like the cops
coming and grabbing the dude across the
street he's your main competitor
grabbing the dude across the street and
you see all the people around you like
nah we still in business over here
we still got that what you need over
here so
I don't I don't I don't feel it's wrong
you're supposed to say it you're
supposed to say yo we still got what you
need adolescent quality of course you
don't got that bang bang for your buck
but he will always be able to reach out
once
Sony and Microsoft sees oh we could just
funnel this stuff for Jim to Jeff for a
fraction of the course and still get the
views let's send Jeff a couple of these
things and we can still hold our own
events and control and narrative and
tell you when it's coming out and what
we want y'all to see in here they're
going to go that way but I do believe
Pax came back and Pax hold on packs were
strong
Pax West is going to be strong I thought
they was going to turn E3 into a Pax
event in
if they let go
where does it go it goes away and Jeff
controls this summer he he will control
the summer so yeah it's over yeah they
definitely I'll jump in it definitely
looks like it um yeah we we kind of knew
the nail was in the coffin with this
particular one when we kept hearing oh
yeah this publisher yeah they pulled out
this one but yeah you know what tested
don't come to your spot
yeah usually usually 10 cents you know
they sprinkle their cash around and once
10 cent figures I don't have to sprinkle
cash around for the games that I got I
don't need this yeah so you know that
I'll start to see a little bit of
writing on the wall but to me even
before that to me they've never
recovered
post pandemic the pandemic did
irreparable damage to them in the sense
of the physical event they were still
you know rounding around around 2018
2019 they still I mean they may have
been on decline but it was still viable
on some level but uh yeah I think once
it went to digital and like you said
King once companies figured that out
that hey how do we pivot how do we
adjust during this period we control the
narrative we do our own show we and you
see the millions of dollars you save
without having to do a booth without
having to fly people out this is
tremendous expense make no mistake and
then you got to think about it yeah
valari spends thousands of dollars or a
very small Booth yeah right that's crazy
so you have the larger booths the larger
footprint you have on these floors
more money goes into these money these
booths right and then on top of that we
forgetting solved from the era of the E3
demo so now as a developer you have to
take away time from the complete
development of the game to have
something just for E3 to show people at
the biggest quote-unquote event so as
much a lot yeah it's a lot that's a lot
as much as we love it and it was the
Super Bowl so to speak and then it's and
it's hated it was nothing like it so I'm
glad I'm fortunate we got to see it but
I do understand coming off a pandemic
and it's like bro let's say you looking
at the books that was 25 million and we
did the same thing had more reach more
effect by doing I mean let's keep it a
bit Nintendo was ahead of their time yep
Nintendo Direct was ahead Nintendo was
the first was like yeah um yeah we out
of here we are I mean we we will still
show some of the stuff on the convention
floor but for the most part all less
money spending we gonna do this uh live
show I mean it's a tape recorded show
you know what I'm saying they kind of on
the trendsetters in that respect so we
gotta only follow suits Microsoft even
pulled their self basically off of the
floor and went over to their side that's
what I knew they was over yeah because
Microsoft in my opinion wasn't there Esa
they are on the board yeah they're on
the board and they're not showing I'm
like
yes internally I don't know what's going
on to Alex Point as far as Keeley look I
don't know what's going on yes in my
opinion it was a little messy but I
don't know the backstory if there was
real beef and what's that expression we
say you know King like you can't if
someone slap you you cannot control the
reaction yeah so we don't know what's
going on I would love an explanation
throughout the last laugh yeah I know
hip-hop was in there he said he knows
some stuff like I would love to know
what really happened that it dissolved
that relationship and then let's be
honest he going extra hard
bro yeah you got listen first of all in
business
you're not gonna let your competitor I
don't care if you wound him
kill the Beast while he's wounded
he destroyed completely he has to he has
to do what he has to do like I said he
represents the digital so for you guys
that be out here now I got my stack
but E3 is dead shut up you supposed to
be on the side of nah EG please right so
if you got your stack you got a champion
E3 you you can't be on both sides of the
fence like that yeah we'll see we'll see
elastic I'll say is um just real quick
before we go into this other thing um
Microsoft
so that'll be another thing not going to
be on the on the floor right you know
and then we saw Eric put out a tweet
that they have a double feature so to
speak right with the Xbox conference as
well as the um Starfield after yeah
Lords you know we've been to a few of
the of the Microsoft conferences and in
person right does Microsoft do a
conference or do they do they stay did
you they're gonna do some small joint
and is it financially viable for the
laws to go to some small hell no
um no let's let's count let's let's
Microsoft calls Laura Cognito Lord
Sovereign Lord attic and Lord King and
says yo we will fly you out put you up
over here
down here and then we'll throw y'all
back to where y'all came from after we
finish no way in hell are we spending
four thousand dollars to go out there
for a 15-minute event they did that last
year you don't remember that
and he was like yeah we have a small
little joint you can make it out here oh
are you copying no we not so how we
gonna go there like we are very very
tiny right so us being this tiny entity
we can't cover it like that so what we
are forced to stay at home but if
they're in our circumference we'll make
it there but the fly out for your little
10-15 minute joint just to say Good Guys
we've seen you no so what about what
about what so you think the the the
physical event is over and the day those
do like a taped sure with the Expo okay
and they're gonna have a Fan Fest
make it financially not viable for you
to figure see okay when we did The Fan
Fest thing and we flew out there if we
didn't get into Fan Fest we still had E3
yeah so we didn't care we still had that
week of e3 right so now the fact that
all right we can do a Fan Fest Fan Fest
only one day
um so you're gonna do the event you're
going to do The Fan Fest thing who the
hell I don't gotta fly out to E3 money
to go home for two days I don't have
that to do that that's not viable
there's not a lot of content in that so
if I'm gonna record I'm gonna see what
they're gonna show anyway to show the
world they give you that first Hands-On
starfish nah bro
if they copied Microsoft I know you're
watching if if if you say yo you know
what we can only take two of y'all we'll
take attic and take a [__] okay right
take attic and take a good place yeah if
if you're gonna take four of us you're
gonna take the whole team and you wanna
do that then take the whole four of us
but what we want is to be shipped out
and shipped back in
if you're gonna give us that little
small show thing but if not it's not
worth it it's not worth it at all
because you're gonna give Jeff some game
anyway that we ain't gonna see and I
actually feel like all this going on
with E3 being canceled like
you know shame on you Microsoft or not
be more transparent with your plans like
there's people out there that have they
they have you know planes booked and
you're not saying nothing much of
anything so it's just like you know to
me that speaks volume itself like if
they had something extremely positive to
say about them being present hardcore at
that E3 time frame this year I feel like
they would have just like the Xbox is
still gonna be there in a bit yes no I
feel that I want to be fair though in
the sense that they were on the board
you have to wait out of courtesy for
them to announce that they are going to
cancel you have to wait you can't be
like yo
we popping even though that's Esa E3 is
going on we doing this because
technically they still have some form of
relationship so I do get what you're
saying though I'm not saying you're
wrong in the sense of it would behoove
Microsoft to let their fan base know
exactly what they're doing you're right
about them all I would say is there is
the politics aspect of you have to be
respectful and let E3 say that they are
officially canceled done and then okay
all right
I think what bothers me about that whole
thing is like I was saying it just feels
like
Microsoft Sony Nintendo all these other
Publishers are the reason it's not
coming in like straight up yeah the
reason is not coming back
of course the last time
let me ask you a question what's up let
me give you a scenario let's go let's
say Microsoft does they have they say
we're going to be open for four days
right let's say because you know let's
go theater let's say they're going to be
open for four days did EA play say that
we're not gonna do EA play because if EA
Play Still is doing EA play thing
remember that's around they wasn't on
the floor they was around yeah they was
always the Saturday was a Sunday yeah
yeah you're right
they were at a different venue as well
then you have Ubisoft that was off-site
always remember we went to the UBC oh
yeah yeah so they off-site and I'm just
giving you the scenario and then you
have different pop-up things there
do you think that's enough
to to get the Lords out there for the
Lord's about there I I would like a
press conference
yeah an event you know saying like to me
the joy of e3 and I've always said this
for me is being in those rooms you know
saying with the Sony joint when they had
a move up from the flute place to the
you know yeah
I was gonna say it's that we've been
doing this this long
and we still it was never at a Sony
conference like that whole time
I believe I would stop being messy but
oh anyway what I would say is just that
yeah for me that's the Allure of it that
that to me is being there in that crowd
announcements live real time Executives
there you seeing what's going on that is
the joy of e3 for me even more so than
the esa because I'm gonna be honest if
Microsoft soldi and Nintendo said hey
we're still doing press conferences and
you know whoever gets in or whatever The
Fan Fest whatever that to me is still
worth the trip that is the essence to me
this four stuff was great after the fact
and you get the play stuff and I get
that but there's no better feeling
exclusive and you're in the building and
the crowd is there it is no better
feeling in gaming than that feeling
right there to me the only way it would
be worth the the amount it would cost to
go out there for something like that is
if we got guaranteed you know we got you
on the conference we got you on Fan Fest
but you know we've been a couple times
and you know some of us get into it some
of the stone I remember solved one year
you didn't get into it and like the
first year it was not a very good
experience for you so it's just like to
me unless I got that you know that tap
on the shoulder but even then like that
first year I didn't I didn't have media
either right so I was literally just
there as a fan hope hoping to get some
kind of coverage right and so when you
have media though it's different because
at least if y'all if one or two of us
has Fan Fest y'all get that experience
and whatever and bring that to the table
and if I could just run around the show
floor and with my bad say hey can I see
this game can I talk to somebody that is
great to me I but when you have neither
that's where it is
exactly just a dude you're just a dude
listen to My Demo bro I used to be in
the same boat like before I open
remember IOP wasn't even worthy
technically by Esa E3 standards and I
had to use like my legit I.T job back in
the day to get a a industry pass right
so Fan Fest was I was tell people all
the time Fan Fest was like a savior like
that was the the greatest I was like oh
my god when I smoked the money room at
the Brooklyn event that's what I was
telling you I was the dude 2015 sleeping
in a mall in West Hollywood on the floor
with random X shout out to suggest who
saved all his guys like the dream oh
yeah shout out to Ed the ruler and I'm
saying Cali Cruise so the dream was
always to get to the conference to be
there and then on top of it what
Microsoft used to do what was dope was
like okay you do that and then it's like
yo you get a chance anybody who did this
sacrifice also gets badges to go into
the E3 convention
before they open it to the public yes
correct and I think the reason that I'm
even harder on on Jeff Keeley because E3
meant so much to me and it's just like
if that's not there and we're all
looking at him to replace it I'm like I
want you to show up
I want you to show I understand that but
I'm with king I don't think it's ever
going to happen because
I it I don't know if this is part of his
argument and why he's doing what he's
doing but the trends are showing these
companies I want to spend that money the
pandemic revealed a lot and I think we
were in a new shift on where the
industry is going and you know it's
unfortunately
all over the time oh listen the
government gave them a ton of money yeah
with that money they hired tons of
people right now those jobs are becoming
obsolete with the Advent of AI with the
the realization that it was inflated
budgets now the budgets is getting back
to normal they can't sustain those
people that was there because they
thought the growth was going to be there
that was uh inflated growth over that
period of time because people couldn't
leave the house so they were stuck in
certain places to do things now that you
don't need that and people can do
physical they can get to spaces you
don't need certain jobs so they they lay
off a lot of people and then they're
looking at where they can save money and
of course that turns into physical
events the first thing is going to die
is physical events and then you're going
gonna go look at marketing do we
traditionally Market the way that we've
been marketing no we can't we have to
scale back How We Do marketing so now
you're going to see a lot of digital
marketing and a lot of spot marketing
the little pop-up that Microsoft did at
the arcade when we was in Boston
that is pretty much how their physical
events is going to start turning out
smaller places random pop-ups and and to
get that Zack Ice in oh wow I missed
that they were here you don't know how
big the venue was but all you see is the
pitches and how much fun people were
having that put you on a wild air all
over the place not knowing that it's a
smaller venue that can be spread across
all or throughout the year so once they
see that it's not going to make its way
back and I and we're going to miss that
so anybody that didn't get a chance to
go all us old heads was holding on to
that good old feeling of what E3 brought
and Jen will never get a chance to
experience the pandemic took away more
than you know because it opened up eyes
in areas where money can be saved yeah
and once you can save a buck bro you're
not going back down that way of spending
needless and that that's why my last
player I don't I don't think it's I'll
be shocked if they try to come back and
I don't know how they can reform it has
to be like a packs yeah it would be
different but we'll see I don't want to
go we'll be like super long with this
but I have to get the second part of
this topic as a combo Zelda tears of the
Kingdom
little introduction gameplay
demonstration of his abilities so Ram
how are we feeling let's start with
addict
I think um what I've seen on Cheers of
the Kingdom makes it look like it's
improved on the issues that I had with
breath of the wild I got to see a little
bit more in terms of how they approach
you know temples and stuff
yeah you know all the gameplay
yeah all the gameplay they've showed I
haven't seen one Shrine that's in the
background
so I'm thinking they probably did hear
the feedback and face it I don't know
yet they clearly heard the feedback when
it comes to Broken uh broken weapons
because they put a lot of mechanics in
the game for that they put mechanics in
the game for like you know uh moving
around the map I think that's good you
know but I do want people to
take a step back in height like don't
over hype this game to where it's not
realistic that they can meet it I think
it's going to be a good game I think
it's good I feel gonna be a game of the
year Contender but I I see people
expecting that captivating moment that
they got breath of the wild and it's
like I said God of War 2018. Ragnarok
was good but it's hard to catch that
that moment you felt when you see
something change that drastically again
and uh that's pretty much all I have to
say about no doubt Lord solve tears of
the Kingdom gameplay where you at with
this didn't watch it don't want to see
it oh you keep it ah you staying dog ah
but no I'm staying dark on actually
watching the footage I couldn't really
avoid the talk around it right so
um even the Dukes themselves
in the streets talking about it
so for me is this from what I've heard
they turned it into even more of an
immersive Sims
yeah you said I could like well it's
funny because everybody talked about
banjo because doing nuts and bolts at
the moment they first saw that car and
they were like yep that's what it is
like you could literally just take
anything and build it and I think
they're expanding upon what people
enjoyed about Zelda the things about
about the original breath of the wild
that you know they got you know millions
of views of crazy videos of people using
the physics and the powers and stuff to
do wild stuff they said okay we're gonna
double down on that and give them even
more agency even more abilities to mess
around with and let the world just be
this thing this this this this expand
the sandbox I think right and to me from
what I heard about that it seems like
they like they're really successful in
that now whether that translates into a
game that feels like it's more of an
expansion upon what we got in breath of
the wild and it's not to addicts point
it's not going to be this wow we're like
breath of the wild is we still have to
see because they didn't show anything
else and I kind of do feel like they're
still hiding a lot
um we don't know what the you know what
the sky islands are going to be we don't
know if they're dungeons to addicts
Point again which is something that it
was highly criticized for we don't know
if there's going to be some sort of
Underworld which could be the dungeons
as well so there's a lot to be known now
from what I did here the stuff that you
see on the surface the world the map
feels like it's
twists and changes on what we expected
from the Overworld with right in in the
same way of a Majora's Mask and things
like that where it was you know it took
that world changed it somewhat but it is
that world right
I don't really see them I don't really
see them giving us
a kind of a carbon copier defer I don't
see them doing that like I just think
they're hiding a lot but again
all right I don't know it's it's
Nintendo when it comes to Zelda I don't
really see them because that would feel
like a shortcut to me regardless what we
say this thing I guarantee it's a 90
crush on metacrity oh okay guaranteed
you know it doesn't matter what they do
it's just oh I mean
Nintendo Nintendo don't get me wrong
my thing is I liked what I I they did in
a lot of aspects on breath of the wild I
just didn't like certain things that
they took away from the foundation to
sell them Zelda like if they if they put
those in here
give it like a new type of story I do
want to understand what the hell is
going on and then you know go from there
then I I'm with it but you know at the
end of the day I'm gameplay over
everything else how do you give me a
good fun game and I'll enjoy it now
regardless if it's gonna be seven eight
nine or ten that's depending on what
they do in the game yeah so I think to
me it's still too it's too early to say
because they're not really showing a lot
10 minutes is whatever I think they
wanted to focus on this to show people
yeah definitely how much they could mess
around with the mechanics in the world
um and I think that excited people that
like to play that way if you like to
play Zelda more straight on and you
don't like to engage in that way you
don't like the cooking you don't like
the you know if you if you really hated
the weapon degradation and even the idea
of being able to just to put make a
weapon in a couple of seconds isn't
appealing to you then none of this stuff
really excites you you just want to see
how how much of a Zelda game it is right
and how much they've deviated so I get
that criticism but uh they're real good
at just keeping stuff on the wrap so
we're not really Gonna Know
yeah I'm assuming they're gonna show us
more at some point which is crazy
because it's only what a month and
change away
but we'll see we'll see but uh I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna judge it yet because
they I mean when it comes to they know
the reaction they got the breath of the
wild oh yeah absolutely it just kind of
feels like they're not gonna drop the
ball on this dude they took six years on
this and the game that's essentially in
the same engine like I don't know no no
bigger like complicated things they're
gonna do too is like upgrade what's
gonna happen to the master story you
mean to make me believe that we went
from having the master sword do we have
to require it like am I going back down
to the Lost Woods to get the match like
there's there's things they gotta answer
but you know I don't want to get a
twisted what they showed was a good
showing it showed you know mechanics
that wasn't in the first one I think
they did their job by that and as far as
like I don't think we're gonna see
anything else I'm gonna be real with you
I think I think they're gonna have
people going blind for this one and
that's fine by me too I'm good with that
no doubt little King you thought the
device perked up when I sent you the
stuff bro thank you let's go because I
I'm one of those dudes I'm not like at
it I don't I don't want to know
everything about your damn game before
come out please please I like the one
there are content creators
[Laughter]
all right you have too many
conversations no problem listen I like
how you do listen don't criticize how I
do do how you do all right you did you
didn't hear me say attic is wrong for
how addict do it let it do it right let
King do the king man let me do me dance
don't mean I have to be that listen man
let me do me I ain't bother you I'll let
you do you
anyway like I was saying
before I was interrupted
oh he found that button yo
I saw the video I'm like it got me so
amp it showed the I see also the draw
distance is better
um they refine the engine that they do
have so if it's the same engine or
whatever they refine the engine is the
content different I believe the content
is hugely different it's going to be
changed inside uh the horse hair looks
better which is crazy I was looking at
that I was looking at Little Things
I know Nintendo gets down to the minutia
of things and graphically they're going
to squeeze this for as much as they can
right I haven't purchased a game for my
switch since uh oh God damn um the first
uh Mario versus rabbits that was the
last time I purchased anything for that
console you know yeah I buy my son his
stuff on you know his switch but this is
going to be a game that I'm going to buy
and I'm going to play my switch this is
the first time I looked over at the
hardware and was like I ain't got to buy
you back
you know he wasn't bothering nobody he
was sitting there he was waiting he
hasn't been updated nothing so I'm gonna
probably take it away
yeah
I'm gonna get a chance to play
um I'm anticipating it it looks great is
it going to be Game of the Year probably
so because the first one had that same
game of the year Vibes uh the wonderment
looks there I love Nintendo products so
again this game is going to fit that
bill now you're going to look at me and
you're gonna say yo King man you're not
keeping that same energy you kept with
Kratos right first of all I never like
your Kratos anyway so um let's keep that
above that's not my credos I'm not into
step daddy Kratos
um that's not me my cradles don't do
that that's y'all
do that my Kratos don't do none of this
stuff if y'all cradles do y'all
did you see a place in that Zelda that
you couldn't get to that was promised to
you
I would have to say no
we're locked in the first one
check it check it check it check it
check it y'all show me Asgard you've
been checked I'm playing this game
thinking I'm getting it so I'm not even
thinking I'm close to end game
I'm saying it because I'm able to go to
every place I'm moving the board around
but go here right go there right so I'm
trying to get to Asgard I'm like
so I paid the seventy dollars and now I
got the Asgard yo
that's DLC all right I believe that
content was locked behind the joint now
if Zelda would have said you see that
Sky stuff up there you talk about that
that's all that's what they doing now
they show you okay no no in this game
Sky stuff is in go to the first game and
tell me so if they would have showed you
Sky stuff and said you can't get up here
yeah okay tune in next time
they didn't do tune in next time to me
so that's not how energy works guys
don't try to duck this thing this fade
is for you and your caught them I do I
do understand where King's coming from a
little bit like I will say that you know
God of War 2018 I would say Zelda breath
is why I felt more like a completed game
like it had a beginning middle and end
yep uh but I can't attack it for that
either I feel like most sequels and
prequels are designed that way for a
reason I can't attack them because they
want to build up a at least a story over
a couple games because that's equivalent
to be he's saying you know God of War
two to three literally that was one of
the the biggest Cliffhangers you could
ever had Kratos going up the you know
the the mountains that's crazy right you
have narrative in the game
Cliffhanger and showing you content that
you think is going to be in the game to
something else it's two different things
do not tell me that do not play that
game that was DLC he was full game and
he said they said you know what no
you're not giving them that we can we
can get them for this we can get them we
will get their money trust don't worry
about that and what happened what was it
13 million in two days they got that
money so they was right they cheated us
they showed as God and then they said
and then or shows up
Cliffhanger good
with you on that thank you
but what I will say is like you know you
had a a final boss that felt like it
could have been the only game like for a
while we didn't know they were making a
sequel to breath of the wild because
breath of the wild was so well done it
could have been
bad game in that segment because Zelda's
always for the people to know Zone has
three timelines it is crazy and I think
people
understood what they got from Zelda now
when you play 2018 Kratos
people knew you were going to have to
play second one going out the back so I
think I get where King's coming from I
just think I I think you know the zero
excuses
that's your favorite oh look I saw the
uh the gameplay joint and um look I mean
we have to be real like they have one of
the best creative sandboxes
as far as that that open world the
things you can do even from the first
one I mean yeah it was so good you know
something's good when people Jack your
stuff oh for sure it doesn't work the
way everything was never for a while
they was this is this is the the list of
breath yeah the breath of the wild
attack everybody's come out with the
world of this you know when you knew it
was the impact literally built an Empire
off of the backs of Zelda breath of the
wild facts like you knew it was real
because everyone gets that shot when
they come out over the mountain cliff
and they Overlook a world like with
breath of the wild first start like the
like that that first opening and it was
like wow this is something special and
that game is near and dear to me like I
went so hard for for switching
everything like that you know what they
were doing because it was new to the
space like they really doing open world
let's go Nintendo and um I didn't have a
problem with with a lot of the things
you know that I guess you know nitpicks
or whatever whether it be the stamina or
whether it be um what's the weapon
breaking I was a big controversial thing
but it made me selective as far as okay
I'm holding on for certain things for
certain fights look I'm gonna be real
with y'all like as the biggest breath of
the wild I Am Lord breath of the wild
that is one of my goat games
I'm not there with this y'all I'm not
and and my thing is it's not that what I
seen was not impressive it was super
impressive like the fusion stuff and you
know I get it from a gameplay standpoint
I'm there the thing I'm looking at it
it's like what other major AAA game
can make a secret and it's literally the
same map like it's the same map we
waited five years so we could say okay
we could go up here now we can we can
look at this guy and we could float up I
agree and I'm just like nobody's allowed
to get away with that like nobody if I
put ghostly Toshiba too and be like yo
it's the same joint but you could go up
there like like no one gets away with
that there's other mechanics that
they're adding to it though it's but
they should have showed that then it's
my thing is but they did they showed the
little kite flying thing what they
showed the reverse power
but if this show called the biggest
thing is like we expect and I think you
know you're gonna see kind of like we
saw Ragnarok like game's amazing but
we waited a long time for this problem
you know what my frustration is I'm
gonna be honest I knew I was felt away
when they said it's going to be breath
of the wild too
just the near the the verb is that it's
breath of the wild why can't it be
another Zelda game so to me you not
ready to jump to the hardware that we
you we know know you need
we all know you need to go on and give
us a new experience you you did it
before you showed us that my thing is
this is the same assets I mean yes it's
creative yes oh we put the logs together
oh yes we we put them I made a mistake
what what I brought Skyward Sword
yo [__]
I'm a fanboy bro I feel you I'm I'm I'm
I'm
Zelda so Zelda is so crazy to me like
I'm a fanboy yeah it's amazing King
can't do anything half
what you want me to support you halfway
I support your own fans we talking about
I I retweet your content
to me to me this game is a vehicle for
what I've seen this is
the first one we heard we we heard you
we heard you didn't like weapon breaking
guess what we got yo we heard you you
know what I'm saying we heard you ain't
like stabbing them now you they
literally say it in advance for the
people that don't like climbing we could
teleport through the thing like I get it
and I'm not saying that the stuff
doesn't look cool and it's not gonna be
fun and I'm not gonna pick it up I'm not
saying it I'm just saying I'm not wild I
am not there's nothing there that make
me go yo this is Game of the Year like
and this is the other thing why are we
here why are we back
why like where's the where's the
narrative trailer like what what's going
on so I get that baby last let me get
these ones do you think okay sorry the
thing is I get it you know there's
probably things you want to show that
you haven't shown yet and maybe they do
things to change my opinion but as of
right now this field dlce to me like I'm
Gonna Keep it a bucket this does not
feel like this this new experience it
just feels like we've put new things in
the spam box so you'd a bit creative
with it's literally the same areas
there's a side by side of IGN from where
the first one and then the second one
wait what's going on they're in the same
areas that we had to draw this is a
little better whatever but to me I again
this is my assumption they are still
held back by the hardware they are not
ready to make a new Zelda so this is
we're going to cash in and and and and
update this world and maybe they pull it
off but as of right now until I see some
narrative until I see a reason why we're
back here I'm not impressed and I'm not
giving them the pass that everyone else
has given them
yeah I mean because being that you you
were supposedly switching I am but now
breath of the wild supposedly it is
because it was you know it was
completely different so you don't like
it no more because she looked the same
she coming back with a new jacket the
same okay so so let me ask you a
question
let me ask you a question if she fixed
the fact that you didn't like the shoes
the last time you have no problem y'all
was complaining I said the weapon
durability is fine that that make I have
you know when people like that they got
to do stamina I used to get into
arguments with Saul's brother because
he's like I hate that bro yeah I love
that I loved it and the only thing I
will concede is attic's point about done
this because he's like cop historically
there ain't gonna be no Savory dungeons
like that I said you you fear I like the
dungeons they did the little gimmick
stuff with moving and stuff cool but I
didn't really have too much a problem if
anyone who says yo the dungeons was
whack like attic say I can't I can't
fight but for me that it was all ready
to go it didn't need anything else can
we just go
just go maybe you maybe go to an
underworld maybe you go
you know Zelda doesn't ever give you the
story up front like we really find out
period and that's my main because that's
what got me scared y'all got I get it
the gameplay is is refined it's
revolutionary Sam the sandbox is amazing
I want to be clear with this sandbox it
is amazing I just want to know
narratively you better tell the most
amazing story as to why we are back
doing the same thing if this is a
prequel a sequel you better give me some
time I bet amiibo still work that's fair
I think that's fair I hope I get a
chance to do the amiibo because I got I
got I got I got a lot of amiibos I think
I think the biggest thing it's like well
when it comes to Zelda they breath of
the wild they show the best up front
they're like you know they they made you
think like the whole game was gonna be
voice then you get it and it's just
these Cuts yeah
I got a point like no but but King if x
Xbox did the next one
and they're and they're really the same
redwood forest
like let's be real people wouldn't be
feeling the same ring we gotta fix that
ring up
imagine imagine you talking to Master
Chief
text dialogue
wait and it only in the in the Cinematic
cut scenes that you see actual voice you
talk about the limitations of a
cartridge man
it's not even it's not even the
limitations of it that's just Nintendo
right it's just the truth like but
that's what they do but it's so it's
okay it's okay they can do this
Xbox
bothered by something that they
constantly do like I'm not gonna it's
like bashing my head up against the wall
they've been doing it why are they
giving a pass for this okay hold up hold
up because they've been doing it for 50.
so just keep abusing people as long as
you keep abusing it with it it's okay
look we got we got to do breath of the
wild was designed for the Wii U yes
so it wasn't even this now we're gonna
get the switch version
not right now this is this is what the
switch we gonna see what the switch can
do no no I'm about this now now I'm
really about this
look let's see I I reserved Jasmine for
for boys
hopefully they changed my feelings
[Applause]
hold on Willy y'all don't even
understand I was fighting these guys
being so I was fighting switch I was
telling people I was telling people
breath of the wild was gonna be fine and
I still correct that so I just gotta
come Critical with that I mean you know
people like to the reason you don't hear
too much about you know console sales
anymore is because damn you're the whole
Generation X PlayStation and Xbox we're
getting demolished by switch sales and
even a couple like for a while that
PlayStation and the switch are still
fighting for that spot so
so Spiderman 2 don't exist now okay
supposedly it's the same New York
is we know that PlayStation loves
narrative experiences and we kind of
expect and we feel like that's going to
happen and Nintendo it's anyone's car I
could literally go across the street and
ask them and they probably wouldn't know
so it's I mean to me I just feel like
breath of the wild was such remember you
had all these zeldas that were in the
vein of Ocarina for a long time right
and then they build breath of the wild
that's different I always thought they
weren't gonna they weren't good that
wasn't going to be a one and done
especially with as popular as it was so
I felt at the very least we were going
to get the look of it again right I
understand the whole map thing
for them to go that route and still take
six years to make this game whatever
they felt they needed to tell I I I
can't not trust them on this one not
fair enough fair enough and like I said
maybe they continue to show stuff and
yeah change my P I'm just talking about
for what I've seen to this point I just
wasn't that impressed not to mention
there's more are you copper hey this
year too of course oh he's confident
he's got one and not to mention there's
you think I know mission to play this
year you got you got Spider-Man coming
out Starfield coming out like is that
one of those incidences where it drops
and marching there ain't nothing else
and there's nothing to play yeah you
could wait a month to play Final Fantasy
so it's just like
cop
s
people weren't going to wait for it I
was saying but there are options yeah
this is the last time the landscape's a
little bit different but it felt very
well
um
you can complaining Cup oh
I'm sorry it's not it it just seems
nonsensical right now you got to explain
it
yeah
as much as they could have gave a little
bit more you know behind the scenes on
what's going on in the story I do feel
like we probably would normally in any
other game wait for that kind of
information they usually don't come out
with plots like that in trailers I want
to know if it's gonna begin and if he
gonna get bit by a zombie I want
something really I think what would
change my opinion if they do something
really demonstrative with the narrative
right it's something really I don't
think they're going to if they do it
change it on his hand and it's something
maybe dark or something like that then
you got it hey see they try it yeah
they've tried Dart they've tried darts
and zeldas they're Twilight Princess and
a lot of people yeah consider that like
one of the worst sodas that has been
made it ain't like that one and I think
that had some of the best temples that's
ever been in Zelda too yep
good all right let's get these super
chats we'll move on we got plaid whipper
platter whipper 2.20 Super Chat Cog need
to react to Lorna Shore that is metal
a little bit oh we got Nintendo we are
gonna do that
I just don't know when
it should be fun uh Nintendo Dio Taco
five dollars Neo games Park did a six
hour podcast by himself last Tuesday I
need y'all to step it up we need that 10
hour Banger give the room what they want
wow
we had four people join the patreon in
this podcast
they want to see that
please let me know what y'all think
about that attack on Titan and and that
um that other stuff that we got going we
got to get back on that soon yeah we
have Robert Kelly
Robert Kelly two dollar Super Chat Jeff
running that Five Below damn Jeff
keeley's the Five Below version of e3
then we have Mr two opinionated two
dollar Super Chat hashtag after hours
addict yeah
he said after I was at it
then we got Robert Kelly two dollar
Super Chat addict Souls the highest
patreon tier confirmed yeah
that we have Nintendo on the otaku five
dollars to be chat How You Gonna Hate
from the outside the game awards you
can't even get in that is true
there we got Joe Repco AKA flame that
was for two years five dollars shout out
to Flame blessings good afternoon IOP I
can finally remember what day it is
thank you guys for all the hard work at
Pax you and the entire team killed it
salute oh much love man what's up
brother
and we got heated heavy 505 member for
33 months Lord bronze
WrestleMania absolute salute a lot of
people out there shout out to attic
yesterday I got a chance to watch
um some WrestleMania because it was
alive on peacock I didn't even know that
oh really yeah so if you had peacock you
were able to watch WrestleMania and um I
got a chance to watch uh some of the the
matches
um yo
I'm kind of kind of dancing and your
boys
um
what's the what's the the the boxing
dude that attic likes uh Jake Paul or
yeah
you know what's funny I was talking to
Tyler when he first announced that he
was going to be a wrestler and he's like
dude this dude's going to go on here
because like Tyler's one of those like I
want you to earn those stripes and then
after he saw him rest a couple times
like I meet my own Crow man he's good
like he's really good he's good I saw
him yesterday he's good okay yeah that's
good man same thing when I saw Bad Bunny
wrestling I was like I don't know he put
the work in like he when he did his
thing I was like oh wow okay that's so I
saw Luke doing
um
like you know how to they run under your
legs to split and I was telling my wife
I'm like yo this dude is tall so they
have a six foot dude jumping in due to
split that's the first time like I saw
um The Undertaker do that yeah I was
like oh he's sorry
let me address this spawn that
King just started no I don't like Jake
or Logan Paul I respect them for what
they've done I don't I don't like attack
them I don't watch any of their content
but I don't attack them for what they do
yeah I don't I don't do that but I I
love the ambition you you got
individuals that have went from podcasts
and went from doing for sure able to
adapt in any environment you have to
admire that he wrestling who would have
thought he wrestling first fighting
Floyd these guys their vision board and
where they want to get to and their
ambition I don't care what you say you
can look at whatever they do but the
ambition and they're willing to go get
it you got to respect it I don't care
Tyler told me that he thinks that that
Logan Logan and like what he brings to
the WWE is going to save it because he
brings all those all those people
you see he brings Jake because yeah
there all the time yes I was there yeah
that that vein that's that's been there
but not been there because young dudes
they'll bring people all in the rain let
them do like a little little scrimmage
and then yeah okay you out of here now
but he's bringing people I saw a clip
where literally they reached over and
pulled Logan's whole crew out it just
started stalling all the time on
wrestling I'm sorry I was just really
amazed that peacock was able to do that
and then I got a chance to see these
dude yeah
is it going on today too isn't it like a
whole weekend event there like multiple
days or something crazy two-day thing
and it's crazy
all right we got
that red flame hold on a second heated
heavy wrestleman okay Robert Kelly Two
Dollars we chat good thing little Timmy
didn't want to see E3 yeah
wow that's a wow right there you know
and it sucks it had a lot of people that
were going to E3 for the first time this
year and they have to change their their
plans their plans is canceled you know
tune in to the Lords and see what the
Lords is going to do I have a
Make-a-Wish thing I want to go to E3 and
they have to go back and say whoa
you're not gonna make it to me
yeah
people keep saying that we need like a
shirt or something I feel like we do but
at the same time like I don't know if I
want to get in that yeah
we good here we go
yeah
R Kelly five dollars they got a lot
riding on the Zelda now Nintendo could
be washed up maybe a 70 I don't know
about Nintendo it could be white the
money Handover fifth maybe a 70 DLC
could be however I think this will be
the Zelda we should have got in 2017.
probably so because remember that Zelda
was a variant of Skyward Sword if y'all
didn't know
yeah you know I mean I'm saying somebody
said they tried it for the first time
bro bro they didn't that was a Scottish
sword bro okay and that's how you got
breath of the Wilds play the foundation
that's right respect the goat respect at
least we did something different for
them yeah we changed it up took out the
motion controls yeah let's go same thing
motion controls removed then we got what
away dragons TV too long I just canceled
my Tesla rental thanks E3
there we got Nintendo the old Taco Super
Chat all these Waypoint Gamers who don't
find the game interesting unless the
experience is hand fed to them all these
incredible tackles all these games
too much work all these Gamers who
accept no narrative and get caught up in
just the gameplay aspect is funny to me
too
I I got a bad call on that you know
every Nintendo game you guys see me
review I say that almost everything get
away with it they ain't got no narrative
no narrative don't do it very well every
year is the same plot we gotta kill him
again I mean I mean Mario Zelda y'all
every game is a variation of it yeah
like there's no they don't challenge
these guys they just handle a fist throw
the Buddy out to the point where the
Zelda that is the narrative yeah the
hero he's the hero of time
dude this is a recycled nerd every game
it's cool you know what I will say I
love how dudes eat that with no problem
don't need a story hold on hold on I got
you I got you Dark Soul games get
destroyed for that factually they don't
have no same energy when it comes to
Zelda look breath of the wild was great
it was fun I had a lot of issues with it
but I acknowledged it was a great game I
just don't think it was the best Zelda
game fair enough
hit that like button I said I'd say
remember uh then we have Robert Kelly
box with level assets worth seventy
dollars of course Jesus it's time to
start putting these dudes to the fire
man y'all got a challenge I know y'all
love them which I gotta challenge them
when they giving y'all the flim flame
and the okay these dudes is just capping
you buying it yeah we'll see we'll see
we'll see now I'm not talking about you
you you you got enough content to fall
back a lot of these dudes this they got
a switch only I know you buying it you
got to switch only you ain't got no
choice hey hold on let me go for your
man I mean gameplay is always gonna be
king for sure I'll take good cable but
you're not gonna demand a good narrative
you're okay with the narrative staying
that way that's why I gotta come for
y'all be real about this narrative y'all
come on and I feel like it's all all
calls really do is like look I love the
game I'm playing it because I love the
franchise but they sh they can improve
on the narrative bam that's all you had
to do Albert G why can't I have both
thank you that's all I'm saying
because it costs more money to do that
Nintendo knows they don't have to do
that to sell that game
absolutely
like I mean Zelda game where I thought
that the story of The Narrative was what
it's always but it's just always
variations on the same thing the hero
time wakes up there's a Calamity and you
gotta uh
also solve we got to remember what Zelda
is about Zelda is like a lot of times I
think
in different
um timelines
to do something crazy and then what you
want them to do that's biscuit talk with
it let's go crazy
the thing is though I can't I can't
agree with the dark thing because they
tried that and the game did not do well
did you like that one with the wolf
Twilight Princess is the darkest Zelda
by far yep
yeah did you like that one with the
Wolves
was lit what you put me on to it
what about the game though when they did
go dog
that's when he was out he was checked
out because you know I'm gonna be honest
I was checked out but graphically they
just don't challenge himself and then it
was that was another pocket you know
what I'm saying but when they stepped up
I'm like yo open world modern sense a
bit let's go with like does this have
anything to do with that steam Bag
Princess it's so it has such dark scenes
where there's a time where in order for
something to stop the main he had to
snap his own neck literally they show
you him doing it yeah absolutely don't
care I want that now though okay we put
it now the modern graphics and where
they at now let's let's do that now all
right we got free R Kelly five dollar
Super Chat Cog I agree breath of the
wild map was empty hopefully tears of
the Kingdom fills up the map that's the
only saving grace if the map is empty
again this game is a l they look like
that looks vertical bro
they did actually I saw they look like
they added more things than me I will
give them that thank you I laughed if
they just if link could just fly and
they haven't shown you that oh yeah I
want to see people's reaction when he
just fly you take off like Henry Cavill
yeah oh if he has the master sword
[Laughter]
get that Zelda uh let me see Nintendo
five dollars we already did the
Spider-Man 2 don't exist now call from
the donuts already so
you didn't watch any of the three
narrative trailers before God you saw it
you're showing your true colors you
acting like we got a 45 minute deep dive
wow the amazing narrative that changed
yes
amazing it's amazing all the different
things I saw a narratively
[Laughter]
I have a different opinion when it comes
to stuff like that like I actually over
criticize games that I love like you
always win yeah I hiked it I I went hard
on it you know breath of the wild same
thing Fallout 4 like I don't give them
pass because of the best franchise ever
like we did with Halo infinite and I I
get it sometimes it's hard sometimes you
get so you know nostalgic yeah I love
Fallout too you overlook things yeah
whatever
they just announced the expansion pass
they milk it
[Music]
the entire Yakuza series uses the same
Maps doesn't matter Nintendo games are
about gameplay and what I saw has me
even more excited because I actually
tells a narrative though like that's not
I don't think it's a different narrative
it's pretty much everything yes
then we got Lord Metroid member for one
year two lots of attack Cog get some
water salty as hell
it is to the kingdom is Game of the Year
gave it a year already
so many objective takes I appreciate
that perspective absolutely Nintendo
game Don and a Metro saluted and we got
gay before Tay remember for 39 months
Lord bronze no updated switch until they
pass 155 million I'm buying the Legend
of Zelda console which is my fifth
switch in six years so you're gonna keep
supporting what I've seen of Tears of
the Kingdom so far so he's gonna keep
supporting and paying money even though
they not giving him what he want for the
hope that they will give him what they
want with the new Switch got you okay I
see what we do with Nintendo please
no one is flying Halo because one day
they're going one day you're gonna give
me a series e no the reason why Nintendo
has this backing is because the Nintendo
built this oh for sure Microsoft hasn't
built this it's going to be a time when
you're going to look up and say your
eyes is backings because you give it to
them no no no I don't I I I vote with my
dollar so if the last game that I played
or purchase was Skyward Sword
then that lets you know they haven't
produced anything that I felt was worthy
of my dollar and now that Zelda gonna
get that bread don't you see the trend
but
um if once Microsoft builds up a catalog
of consistent great games and not saying
it to Zelda ain't gonna be great the
Zelda's gonna be great it's going to be
worth that 70 bucks or whatever not
really 70s you know so same engine
I think you're wrong but I feel you but
when Microsoft does that then they then
we're going to look back and say yo why
is Microsoft getting this slack right
but not until they build a catalog they
got to get busy I just I I don't agree
with you because I think PlayStations
got that and they still get criticized
for this kind of stuff well Craig Place
Nintendo fell back on their Laurels but
I get that but imagine like
Nintendo really never went any direction
when it comes to voice acting like the
majority of their games don't do it
right like these other platforms don't
get that benefit of the doubt like even
a little bit that's true
that's why they could stay in their own
lane and it doesn't matter until
somebody else tries to invade their Lane
in a real way they're not going to
change anything that's just facts I was
working for sure yeah Nintendo Taco
again five dollars Super Chat just the
abilities shown gives infinite
possibilities to the gameplay and they
haven't shown much that immersive
gameplay will be better than ever and
that's where I I agree right is it to me
the sandbox that they've expanded upon's
name is crazy but if that's not your bag
if you don't get joy out of that I can
see you look at it be like wait a minute
what what what new is there for people
so I get it it's like two people it's
two different yeah yeah two different
Gamers and for people who love just that
gameplay aspect that's for them I I just
want that and more that's like other
exactly black Ronin three five seven
twenty dollar Super Chat thank you sir
Nintendo drops Nostalgia games and gets
a pass for some crazy reason stop giving
Nintendo y'all money demand more also
can we address that Unreal Engine 5 to
hellblade 2 demo Chris Hart talking
about it looks so real so this is the
thing right when it comes to the game
you can't I understand all the all the
other Nintendo isms that we have issues
with when it come to gameplay though and
that's why you look at what you can do
in this Zelda game oh for sure why
people are excited about it that's it
because yo Zelda came out
breath of the wild came out and kicked
Horizon in the for sure gameplay wise
for sure it was just a game that cost
God knows how much more money to me
and it's just it is that thing about the
gameplay so I get it but one of the best
creative sandboxes ever like exactly
exactly
on some on some just on some very very
light Hardware compared to everything
else that it was working you know what
once I get my stuff up and running I
think I might stream like Ocarina of
Time or something on the channel I'm
coming from it's cool I'll stream the
master quest on the show yeah and then
hellblade yes that looks insane once
again I say all that and I said okay
you're showing me what I already knew
it's gonna look good where's the
gameplay where's the gameplay not for
that all right hold on we jumped a
little bit we gotta come give me
fortunate the five dollar Super Chat
making boo-boo
guess we're the only ones that
appreciate brightness Zoda is the
position to be
great and Game of the Year
I'm down for Cog to react to metal [__]
I think you'll find that metal is great
for working out and relieving stress
give it a shot bro I'll tell you man I
got that green thing don't you dare look
this up until you read yes I got that
Green Day like that'll count that'll
count don't listen to Cog boy
yeah we got Nintendo Taco once again
five dollar Super Chat I'd rather have
new gameplay features than a new story
with the same generic gameplay for the
last 10 years Sony and Xbox ain't doing
both all right but here's the thing and
we got to be real now
all this gameplay
is improvements on things that people
had issues with the first one so it's
more like hey y'all didn't like weapon
durability you're gonna fuse or you
didn't like climbing we're gonna Ascend
so this is more of Corrections of things
that than opposed to yeah you know what
I'm saying that's what I'm saying I
think the Detroit with the Wrath and put
stuff together that was cool but I'm
again I I'm not saying that this is so
wowing on the gameplay side even so
you're you're saying that in order to
wow you they're gonna have to show you
like a narrative
focused me was the fact that it's it's
so the same when I looked at the Skybox
and it was the same like until they
showed me like the maybe completely
locate like King is saying you go the up
the upper is so different than maybe and
then when I saw the enemies the upper
look literally just looked like the land
just in the air yeah okay when I saw the
enemies and I was just like the with the
constructs listen they don't got the
power to do what you would ask I think
that's what it is you're not asking too
much for
did you notice that they they like to
highlight that there was one new enemy
look at this new enemy like yeah I think
it's gonna be more new enemies that's
going to follow but also and I get to
say this if the last one was tied to the
Wii U I believe that the the switch will
have a little bit more diversity a
little bit more robustness when you
looked at the grass I thought they had
more grass textures and stuff like that
more swaying I saw the horse looked a
little bit better I saw little things
that us that that I saw graphical
upgrades in very minor very incremental
I don't believe that the Tegra chip was
uh uh more than what was that that was a
power PC chip that was inside the Wii U
I believe I don't know
um or AMD chip probably I don't know but
at the same time we're going to see a
little bit of difference
I just want to give it the benefit of
the doubt because this game took five to
six years to make I think Nintendo
poured a lot into it and I don't don't
think they give you enough story up
front
I think the story will you know unfold
while we playing I I'm giving it hope
because I got hope for this game because
it's the only game that I was looking
for no
ask him I'm gonna put a poll in the chat
asking what the best Zelda game is
continue yeah we're good we're caught up
all right cool all right let's go
Jesus Christ is 4 o'clock
um XBox friends and family addict is you
you want me to set it up yes yeah so it
looks like the price is leaked online in
New Zealand shot the inside gaming he
said from a Twitter user jaw muncher
revealing that the friends and family
Game Pass uh would set people back about
40 however it's understood that the
pricing in New Zealand and conversion
rates would put it around 25 so no
pricing if it can be purchased annually
but as far as the benefits um includes
friends and family outside your
household enjoy hundreds of games
together new releases on day one each
account has their own history
achievements gamer tag and sayings play
at the same time on Console PC and cloud
with games added all the time there's
something new and then even though again
there's no official statement by Xbox as
far as you know us but the information
leaked on New Zealand but then I believe
Xbox does have a page on the all about
Xbox uh Game Pass and friends and family
and it says at this time Game Pass
friends and family is only available in
Columbia Chile Hungary Ireland Israel
New Zealand South Africa and Sweden so
yeah it looks like it's it's leaked and
it's out other places where you at where
wait hold on hold on hold on take that
down and put Skyward Sword up in them
and get that off of there what happened
because he got that up there with no
Skyward Sword and without Skyward Sword
you don't get no breath for a while so
let's get real what's going on I'm
looking at his pole that he got there oh
I'm like what is happening
God say that again oh I'm sorry as far
as the the availability of where it's at
uh like kind of like the whole oh my
gosh what was it listening oh pretty
much friends and family was leaked so to
speak you know saying by um again this
user John Munch or whatever and um
pretty much um they offered uh uh
basically what the features were include
friends and family outside your
household 100 games together releasing
on the new releases on day one each
account gets their own history
achievements gamer tag and say his play
at the same time on Console PC and Cloud
the price uh looks like it was about
um what they saw is understood the price
conversion would be about 25 for us
that's what it seems like they're based
on the conversion and yeah it looks like
they do have it on the site for Xbox but
only available in Columbia Chile Hungary
Ireland Israel New Zealand South Africa
and Sweden no U.S so far
I mean at this point you know I do
I did you see the people that saying it
was forty dollars yeah yeah people were
flipping out my face
you know this is something they need I
feel like
this is the direction they need to go to
you know get this to the to the masses
because obviously you can get like for
you know 25 you can get I think up to
five right
I mean
the majority people are probably gonna
have like two Max of three and you got
to think how many people
when it comes to like giant families
everyone just plays off one account you
know what I'm saying like I think that
would encourage more money going into
the ecosystem I think it's important man
obviously we got to see how it works
you know I'm very curious if they try to
you know back pedal the game sharing
thing with the home share I I'm kind of
curious if since this is happening they
might try to pull that back but I'm
curious but I'm actually commented on
that they they acknowledge it they said
uh shout out to Buddha if he's in there
because me and him had a discussion
about this so I got to get Buddha's
props they do acknowledge it here they
said Xbox Home console is an existing
feature that allows you to share games
with content with other people who sign
into your home console on their profile
however it is limited to that device so
friends and family must sign in the
console you identify as your home
console to access those benefits but
they said yeah the when you share
um with friends and family the primary
account holder and up to four additional
members get their own unique access to
all Game Pass Ultimate Game content and
and benefits regardless of what device
they play on all the people you invite
can play at the same time same time even
the same game that's that's kind of lit
yeah
as long as I don't get rid of game
sharing because I don't use Game Pass
like that
you know it's something like from Atlas
sneaks on there I'll use it but besides
that I I I couldn't tell you besides
like Persona I think that was like one
of the only games I played all last year
a lot of game pass
yeah Phil
real feel
as long as they don't get rid of that uh
you know I I think to me
the majority of the games that I want to
play don't end up on Game Pass so you
know when it comes to like a unique
Indie that I I didn't buy it at day one
or I didn't get like a review code to
review it and that shows up there I
might try like launch it just to see how
it is something like that store but as
far as like
really captivating it
as long as they don't take like the game
share because I do use that yeah uh then
I I'm okay with that because if they
were taking if they were going to get
rid of game sharing and replace uh the
family plan I'd be against it really
like I don't want that right away if
they did that I'm just curious because
when it comes to the fanbook land it's
only cedricated to like the things on
Game Pass like I don't I don't play
anything on their house
you know when I talk to you know my game
share partner I'm like y'all go buy this
game this game this game this game this
game nine times out of ten all those
games out on Game Pass so it's gonna
cost me
quadruple more money than it would to
get that okay yeah I see what you go
mm-hmm
so your thoughts sir
um I don't know that I don't know when
we see that here because when it comes
I mean it is this is the the best market
for Xbox
if they're eating good here it is no
reason to put a buffet out well you
could sell everything peace are you
applying that it's selling it put out in
other regions for other reasons yeah
exactly I think the language is a test
Market
boys
I do want to clarify real quick I'm
about to end the poll and put more Zelda
games so you guys want to vote before I
end okay nobody voting in that poll
until
disgusted man stand
ing buddy let that poll be what it is
so yeah to me that's the thing I don't
know when we see it here if it's soon
that'd be great
um I want to know how if once they do it
I want to know how that works with
people that have existing Game Pass
ultimate sort of subscriptions can you
stack them on top of one another because
if we you know it'd be great if if the
Lords could have one and you know and we
could just all play from that one
account but each of us has our own right
now so how does that work in terms of
consolidation right does is that a thing
um but overall I do think that this is
the move right this is this is the kind
of L money wise that they're willing to
take in order to continue to to sort of
proliferate Game Pass and all these
different spots and now when you talk
about
all these different cloud gaming deals
they've made with these other providers
you know you they they don't care
necessarily they want the engagement
they want the number of people they
don't care about what it costs or
whatever now
all of that also when you point to the
fact that they've eliminated the one
dollar right they've been limited that
one dollar thing so ultimately
what we're going to start to see is that
you know the price of Game Pass will go
up at some point probably sooner rather
than later that's my thinking
where you at with this our friends and
family
okay so like the beta boys is out there
they're gonna test it they're gonna see
how it goes in the markets those are the
markets that has the least amount of
growth when it comes to Game Pass so you
put that out there to see if you can
encourage more people to add more people
to get the more value so the more eyes
that's on your product this is how you
test better product and if it's not uh
gaining Traction in certain areas you
put it so that it's undeniable so you
have 25 and say it's 25 over there yo
five dollars per dude you add these
dudes in you'll try this
those dudes is gonna it's gonna be
somebody outside of the group so that
six dude is like I gotta start a group
of five right so he starts a group of
five and the more engagement more people
that means more eyes that means more
purchases so the more DLC is going to be
purchased more in-game content is going
to be purchased more stuff is going to
be purchased reason why uh us is uh the
last to probably get it like Sovereign
said they're making money hand over fish
head and they're strong in this section
facts once they see the growth over
there and they can look at the metrics
over there they can see the pricing wise
that would happen here so now you price
it in a way that it's still formidable
and it allows uh more people to engage
because because you're going to lose
some subscriptions because most of the
people is tied to somebody else right
like I'm tied to my son so when we do do
the plan is it does it work for me does
that work you know so you know Iron
Lord's weird I use the hell out of Game
Pass yeah right so I don't know like you
heard addicts opinion of it addict is
more towards the uh sharing game sharing
yes
my game sharing is with my son
he uses my uh my game pass ultimate and
then we game share right so that's how
that works now it'll be able to hey I
get a group with iron Lords is the group
we be able to share more games as far as
Game Pass goes
it doesn't change the core of how Game
Pass is going to work it's just going to
inflate the numbers is it always a good
thing to have options yes you'll still
be able to purchase Game Pass without
friends and family right you'll still be
able to do that price is going to raise
when the ABK deal goes down because
you're going to have more inside of Game
Pass right could you imagine going in
and having every Call of Duty off the
rip you could sell it on the that's the
thing this you could sell it to so many
people just off the Call of Duty
so it's it's a great thing I can't wait
for it to happen here uh do I see the
numbers increasing you have to think
outside the box in order to to make it
happen and remember guys I know you're
going to say nah there's no way because
I saw a lot of you guys talking about oh
Microsoft is taking away the dollar deal
mm-hmm they're taking away your joke
they're taking away your biggest joke
the biggest joke I can get Game Pass for
a dollar it's over you can't get it for
a dollar now you gotta get it and why
would you even care if you can't get it
for a dollar no more when all that's
what you was doing was clowning so
obviously you worse the dollar dudes
staying on that dollar deal right now
they're taking you know they're taking
it you the guy that went to McDonald's
and was looking for the dollar menu
no more it's over damn no more eating
the way you eat now you gotta pull me up
cash gotta come out your pocket or you
gotta get five friends now you can't do
it in secret because those five friends
is gonna fraud you out nah I play with
EXO and and so and so oh he has a
PlayStation Channel what yeah your
business is going in the streets
somebody in your core four group is
gonna snitch you out so I can't wait for
them to drop the dollar deal and get the
family plan mail up so you guys got to
really get inside and it's gonna be you
know it's funny I find it hilarious that
they dropped the dollar deal right
before redfall and start yeah
because I was like look man part of your
work party's over tell the rest of the
crew it's all down like the gays are
here that was cute like look is I said
it'll do
it's called the the acquisition you know
what I'm saying but you know the growth
phase and we and once you I'm in the
beginning man we was at E3 they was
giving them joy sound like hotkeys
remember attic how many for like three
years I didn't bro we was yeah that
first couple of years old Game Pass was
announced because they tried it was
literally I remember one of the meteors
at E3 I had a year like Years cards yes
on the table facts and obviously I don't
know if they had a way to just to stop
you from taking multiple but to me I
didn't see no one stopping them so yeah
no I could have literally took a couple
years of Game Pass and I don't think
that it could have been stopped yeah
like once once they got to that that
metric point that they are not they're
never done but the most I will see is
like oh there'll be a deal here a
weekend here uh you know a month here a
day a couple months that kind of stuff
but that was down stuff that's a wrap
like I knew that wasn't gonna laugh they
people thought that was gonna be
consistent for the cycle the duration of
game fast I got a joke for you but um
yeah at the end of the day with this
fighting over this Zelda pose in the
chat yeah they go yo betray and I've
seen Adventurer down in Taco beefing
about which oh this is fire I like it I
like that I like the Nintendo dudes
actually I'm deliberately I'm
deliberately keeping Skyward Sword for
like one of the last ones that's when I
vote I'll vote with my vote then anyway
look so uh look with this right um
yeah like I think that this first of all
what this plan so bad for people who
real quick who y'all who killed you I
claiming who's gonna be down with the
score well that's the thing about us for
then we gotta claim one more child
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you my
son I'll give you my son yeah
it's gonna be funny to know who in the
five and not in the five what people do
that
I wanted to see the drama
actually do a second one because that
because you know we'll do it we're doing
iron bank one right and then and then
we'll have the family one because I
could put I could put on actually uh uh
Kai I could put on my nephew my niece oh
they're gonna be in love they're gonna
be oh my God
absolutely and I'm with kick I don't
think it's good I'm with King in the
fact that even though I'm I want this so
bad right now in the whole bucket King
is right they know this [__] no way
in the hell
you gonna wait while we test this other
stuff situation yeah and look it makes
sense because you want to grow you want
to get more users in that engagement in
these regions that either you have no
presence little presence and you're
trying to establish yourself then it
becomes you know tell a friend tell a
friend you know and and getting people
in the ecosystem and once they're in the
sweat King is right they are going to
spend money they are going that
transforms into oh I got all these games
on Game Pass okay here's this you know
skin DLC expansion what have you that's
how that's how the engagement in the
training starts running so I completely
see where they're going with this um to
Addicks point he made a good point about
game sharing I'm hoping based on the
fact that the verbiage is there that see
that seems to me that game shame is not
going away and that's another thing so
for people who don't want to engage in
that and want to have their full Library
shared with one person having that
option still available do you think they
had those internal talks
I think so because they know people are
sharing this is something that they are
aware of
um digital I don't know from a metric
standpoint may be beneficial for them to
keep that program the way it is because
if they would lose less guys they were
bleeding money doing that that way they
would cut that off automatically yeah
yeah so they cleared that was part of
the rich the initial DRM yes so that's
why they did they left it there and if
you remember
when the initial Dr Ram started they had
a friends and family version already
embedded into the UI if you look at the
Xbox UI like I had Mark's move down
remember they had that that convoluted
they just didn't explain it well when it
first came out but they had a version of
friends and family they were trying to
stay be with the Xbox one it's just they
were so aggressive with the online
everybody took it negatively and they
were like okay kill the message you know
let's take this digital online on things
so now we're at the point where we're
here now which is kind of the same
message but put it on right back burner
to introduce it better exactly Microsoft
did innovate in that sense and now they
have the subscription service with the
games and now it looks like it's all
coming together I think it's great
service I want to shout out my man um
Jovan I think I always butcher your name
from Iceland brother you got to tell me
the correct pronunciation he he made a
good point though because he's in
Iceland they've got to do a better job
of promoting these services in these
other regions you can't just throw it
out there don't you know Twitter you got
it you gotta figure out a way to really
get the masses no because he tells me
all the time he's like mad of my friends
don't even know about this there's no
advertising this you need to have pop-up
events for Game Pass they need to they
really these are the reasons because I
do feel that's the right approach you
put it in these regions you I was
surprised Japan ain't on that list off
to be honest well actually after after
the the latest information you know I
think Japan is on all of Microsoft's
list yeah we'll see you know they
approved that that version of the APK
team
shout out to Japan know what to do
yo ask your parents say [__] let me be
your Chicago listen man I ain't claiming
no more kids man y'all got them
or dudes try to get friendly now when
they find out who their father is
bm's gonna get lit in a second
I got no kids in Chicago right now
got no extra C but it's gonna be funny
because I think it will cause little
beats with friends that know where they
at with certain things cool
yeah they got a couple super chats down
crazy
Nintendo Taco ten dollars of attack oh
Lord fuse is just a correction what the
correction for any other Dev would be
taking out weapon degradation Ascend is
not only a shortcut both will be used
for puzzles yo salute if you like
putting the twig with a rock together
and you think that's awesome don't let
me stop your joy brother cause you
clearly love this and I want you to have
the best fun you can have with it you do
that twigs and the Rocks together
primary account can still game share
their game pass otherwise game share
stays the same friends and family takes
away ability to use codes for get uh
Game Pass or gold have to get it
directly at full price from Xbox us
maybe fall okay so no more little codes
no more little shites and stuff like
that you go You're Gonna Pay Direct
hahaha
when they try to do it too aggressively
and yeah just let it slide and die keep
keep giving them the wax stuff so people
will be like I don't know the only
reason they haven't got rid of gold is
because they want to keep continue to
charge for both of those so but this is
the thing though they got to change it
they can't do like a five dollar
increase to Ultimate at the same time
they eliminate gold because people just
gonna put those two together but like oh
wait a minute they're eliminating this
they're they're eliminating it in name
and they're gonna still give you those
games in Game Pass ultimate eight days
you're gonna be like oh wait a minute
this is why we're paying five dollars
extra obviously there's gonna be more
games ABK hopefully done by that time
whatever that's not the narrative it's
gonna be painted it's gonna be the
narrative charging us five dollars more
to give us that's just the cheap dude
that don't want to upgrade yeah
I'm only spending sixty dollars I don't
want to spend the 180 in one day
wow okay
is awesome oh let me see Robert Kelly
two dogs with chat friends and family
more like snitching and frauding
yo he's stupid we don't do that over
here Sony does that sir you will be
addressing that in the next time
you know what I'm gonna let you hate in
peace okay let me take your joint it's
just one man's a pinky that's all that's
something
let's get this Papa this is what y'all
here for you already know what it is
um Sony man we got some news we got some
news about your attention in reference
to 11 members of Congress arguing that
Sony is unfairly hurting Xbox in Japan
shout out to Steve with attilo shout out
to axis gay I see the tiller was at the
cable ones I believe right what do y'all
we pulled up on him he was yeah
the crew
um yeah so this is this is what's
driving the news on policy makers or
saying that Sony's business practices
and it's native Japan are blocking U.S
companies from competing in that
country's gaming market and could be
running running a foul of U.S Japan
trade Deals they said what they're
saying is today we want to we write to
you to bring your attention the
imbalanced Japanese video game Market
which we are concerned may be a result
oh Lord maybe a result of a
discriminatory trade practice that could
violate the spirit it of the U.S Japan
digital Trade Agreement in one of the
letters they said uh also uh another
Republican letter was said that
PlayStation has 98 of the high-end
console Market signs deals designed to
keep hit Japanese games away from
Microsoft and says such moves May
violate Japan's Anti-Trust laws and then
they go on to say
um that um Sony has had a steep
advantage over Xbox for Japan for
decades they mentioned the Final Fantasy
stuff and then you know
you're messy oh yes and then they just
basically said now it's on Tony decide
as far as how you know it's going to
happen with the government and um them
raising this issue you know to the
Japanese government to identify
additional barriers to American
companies and accessing the Japan
Japanese gaming market so yeah this is
this is King's time part two today
we'll focus on this for
I want to uh say real quick King you got
your Skyward Sword and it's hard for I
live between
uh yeah I saw what's happening not messy
it's winning right now so continue I
know I know it's okay your thoughts on
um is is do you feel that they're being
justified by this they feel that uh
Congress feels that Sony's unfairly
hurting Xboxes
Sony thought they would be able to
snitch his silence Troy Avenue
yo y'all thought y'all's gonna Troy Ave
this is Snitch and quietness and nobody
was good nope
and then they said that you had to take
the stand
cause they found you had guns in your
car oh man that's gonna have to tell
but this is what happens when you have
little wallets going up against dudes
with trillions uh-huh it's a word out
there that y'all don't like but let me
let me let me tell you what this word is
lobbyist
so they looked over at the chat gbt
owners and said
bill went over there and said Chad gbt
how can I hurt Sony
VT came back and said
hurt them in their Homeland
hurt them
out of so Microsoft call over their best
lobbyists said yo Byron
oh executive order what
man Sony's been hurting Microsoft that's
our Microsoft is here with us right so
yeah pirate say yo well I gotta be
firing
Joe Byron
yo yo this is sitting over our best and
I would brightest over there to figure
that out
and now they looking into what you been
doing in Japan
now they look they pointed over
that your co-conspirator Square
why why aren't the games going to
Microsoft
what had happened was
yo I am so happy now that y'all being
exposed all around the boards especially
in your home world right
Microsoft is going to be able to play
freely over there now
no more fear no more bullying no more
telling people now you can't work with
them they're gonna snitch on you right
to the government the government is
involved now this is the best part
imagine you you did the check stole you
wrote a letter you wrote a letter to the
judge and the judge indicted him
yo imagine you snitching and they
looking into your book
stupid thing to ever happen now we gonna
find out what's really going on over
here what you really been doing in Japan
how you've been really blocking
Microsoft everybody always said why
don't Microsoft go to Japan and why
don't Microsoft go over there and get
these Studios why is it Japan they can't
get a foothold there now we know
and now it's gonna change
this is I just I saw this and I know
that that now Byron's on the case
um
addict uh your thoughts on this though
you are very in tune with the Xbox's
lack of
I would say parody with um Japanese
titles specifically Final Fantasy I know
that's kind of near and dear to you but
what are your thoughts on on this do you
make anything of this with this apparent
legal I mean political action
it's like somebody was trying to use a
trojan horse but they came out before it
got in the other town
you played yourself you know I'm not
saying nothing's going to come of this
but it's like but I will say that next
time PlayStation tries to buy something
they're going to look at stuff like this
like look like why are you doing this
over there and the fact that Japan
sided with
Microsoft because they they approved the
deal didn't they yeah oh yeah you talk
about the Japanese yeah
that's crazier than the other one
because a lot of people don't understand
like the way things work over there like
people are calling out Japan
the Xbox can't compete over there and to
me them approving that is like the
Japanese
well the Japan government's like you're
kind of right so here you go we're going
to accept this we're gonna we're gonna
open the floods uh and it kind of shows
like not necessarily disrespect to Sony
but it's just like look you might be
native to this country but uh we we
about what's right and I and I got to
give it to the Japan for that and it's
just an actual question just not to
interrupt you do you think they decided
that right after uh uh Joe uh Byron
called them
Joe Byron called over and was like yo I
heard I heard y'all over there blocking
my man
yeah
do you think that had anything to do
with them saying yo approve that deal
because Byron's on the phone yeah
oh man addict your answer it just
depends man you know I I'm more curious
if this is actually going to mean
anything in the long run this might be
one of those like banter talks happens
on Twitter and then a couple weeks you
never hear about it again I don't think
it really means too much of anything I
just think it's one of those things
where it's like at least Japan and some
of the people in our government actually
care what's going on in the industry you
see something like that like okay so
there are Gamers that's in Congress that
understand okay you know I get what
you're saying Sony
well what's going on over here in Japan
because you know we saw so much
Spotlight going on Xbox in their
acquisition no one ever brought up what
PlayStation's been doing and this is the
first person you know I don't
my respects off to that dude so much if
I live if I lived in the sector I vote
for him in the next primary yeah
I'm curious of your thoughts on this
um what are we feeling the Congress
action uh Sony unfair saying Sony
unfairly hurting Xbox in Japan I mean I
just think it's funny because it's like
dude this is my only beef with all of
this
Sony do what you got to do to block I
don't have any issues with you doing
what you got to do to block this
all fair love of War actually but my
problem was always the fact that you
were blatantly pointing out things that
you're doing and it's just like and
nobody's calling this out like nobody it
was literally like putting the videos
shout out to Mr show That's a classic
[Music]
so it's just to me that was my only I'm
like it's no one seeing this is no one
going to be like hey wait a minute
they're too excited about pointing out
all of these things let's look at why
they're excited about pointing out all
these things that Microsoft's supposedly
doing and it's just to me that was the
only thing can someone please have some
real not bad faith arguments that that
actually makes sense and the fact that
it's getting pointed out now
I don't know it's hard to tell if Sony
was just saying you know what let's play
this card until we can't play it anymore
and they pull our card on our
foolishness
and see where it gets us right because
at the very least the conversation got
at the very least they put a monkey Wren
monkey wrench and and like the
smoothness of this deal going oh for
sure for sure like to attic's point
though I don't know if even the fact
that our government is pointing this out
and Japan has to acknowledge it I think
that's good because it's out there right
so I went to Ethan now that hey wait a
minute like if you think about all these
deals that are going on and the deals
that are about to happen hello Final
Fantasy 16 where is the Xbox version
nowhere to be seen Final Fantasy 7
remake where the Xbox version nowhere to
be seen their real life examples of of
Sony's practices in play right now that
can be pointed to and be like hey wait a
minute hold on you're saying all this
stuff but look at these examples that
are happening right now that you
continue to do so for me in the long
term does that do I think some
legislation comes of it no it's out
there though and to addicts point at
least people are getting the right
information and and arguing and thinking
about these things in the right ways as
opposed to all just you know not knowing
anything about the industry whatsoever
and having these blind sort of arguments
about stuff and I go back to the that
Meme I saw about the tick tock whether
where the where the whatever the
congressman's like uh can The Tick Tock
take over my internet
yo uh you you need to utilize the
internet to utilize Tick Tock sir that's
what you mean oh but you couldn't take
it over I'm huh well I mean it but this
goes to the level of obliviousness that
you're kind of dealing with with these
people that can actually have power over
we're yeah we don't normally get
political on here but like the movement
I'm seeing on Tick Tock like they're
pretty much like look we're gonna make
an interactive math and we're gonna
we're gonna put your District on every
point of people who voted to end this to
kill Tick Tock and if you kill Tick Tock
you will be unemployed next year
that's crazy it's insane it's insane so
to me it's just that I I like the fact
that that it's out there the
conversation could get serious if
somebody really decides that they want
to follow this thread and really make a
thing of it
um but again I don't I don't really see
it happening but I just like the fact
that you know the foolishness is out on
the table you can you can't hide behind
the ignorance anymore so that's what I
like no it's it's you have to but this
is absolutely hilarious we just have to
admit like this is because like you said
solve you know one of the things that
when we look at it objectively and when
we heard okay what's Sony's arguments we
know they're gonna go hard as they
supposed to jibron is supposed to go
hard for his stakeholders I get that you
know my thing is okay what are they
gonna say right to to block the deal
because you know I'm going to Lulu we're
gonna block this here right respectful
respectfully so they said it was
aggressive coloring
they point out real quick before we move
on the final Zelda hosting all right no
doubt it's all the winners from the
other four oh okay there we go there we
go final four so like look you know I I
get it you're supposed to do what you
got to do but the thing is I just want
to know what the arguments are
I've never saw those arguments it's
harming competition
and I I was just really surprised that
lawmakers didn't understand how the game
Market works right it really put this
whole situation proved to me remember
when they had to go out there and bring
all three of the consoles it was like
this is how it works this is this is how
it works yes it shows you how
outside like because obviously every
industry gets a certain amount of you
know gaze from from governments but it
shows you how much the gaming industry
has evaded government gauges because no
one knows anything about the gaming
industry when it comes to stuff like
that it's funny they know they can make
money in it their eyes will be all over
it they did what they needed to do they
had to create the esa right to to police
after hot coffee and all this other
stuff and and but that's after that like
okay they can police themselves they're
fine you know whatever this is the first
time eyes have been on this in a long
time
you know shout out to Microsoft having
great lobbyists and you know talking to
buyers look you know like I said the
funny part about it like I said you know
those kind of bad faithy arguments in my
opinion because I looked at it
objectively I'm like okay more people
are going to have access to this it's
not being taken away from you but you
are saying that this is harming
competition okay fine so it went and at
some point there was different Roblox
for Microsoft so now it seems that this
is turning away in their Direction now
right it seems that you know the EU is
going to be in board it seems that you
know you know obviously like addict
mentioned you know Japan just went and
went through Brazil it went through very
quickly you know and it's going making
the rounds I I just think it's it's the
age-old meme kick like the more you f
around
the more you will find out because at
the end of the day it's like you you put
you you do I get it you riding and you
you stakeholders and you financially
this does not benefit you I get that
you're gonna kick and scratch and do
what you got but the way you read about
it
and some of the bad face arguments and
then some of the you know we can't wait
for them to look at remember the
statements we can't wait for the CBS see
a man FTC to look into this deal this is
harming We Stand remember all of that
but he didn't know who big homie was
right so they don't know that Microsoft
knew Byron and when you go to war with
someone who got a bigger War chest
expect at some point there will be
retaliation and now we're seeing
Microsoft do they Petty like oh you know
what we gonna look into um Japanese
Market because we feel you know we've
been blocked over there for a long time
so how about we started to investigate
like it's getting to that that messiness
part now I'm with soft I don't think
anything really amazing gonna come with
this but would be interesting the only
thing I care about is I'm very curious
about the structure of their exclusive
deals for example like addict is
mentioning with a final fantasy I'm very
curious that the language the verbiage
the terms because it will to kids boy I
will say even though I don't subscribe
to this
I will say it would be interesting if
there's any
parody verbiage it would be interesting
I'm not saying it's there I'm just
saying I would love to see the nature
even we used to say this addict during
the destiny days with exclusive content
with on Sony and Activision and how
things were locked up and secretly
extended I would love the verbage of
potentially The Game Pass
does this is the language that says they
cannot do this it cannot do that I am
very very curious so this is a situation
where yeah this is where you keep
playing that game and now things look
like it's going to Microsoft and now
Microsoft is on the attack to now mess
you up this is a bad situation because
at the end of the day even even if
nothing
legally comes out of it what could come
out is information that no one was
really privy to and that could make them
look bad like that doesn't look good but
that's the thing right when you really
look at the practices this is the thing
right let's say it's difficult for a
Japanese company to justify putting
certain games on on an American console
where the type of games they play are
assumed to be somewhat different right
and they figure monetarily it doesn't
make sense all the things we have to do
to invest in that platform don't make
sense
fine that's one argument now if you
really do couple that with realities of
like hey but on top of that we're like
nah we give you incentive not to do it
anyway even if you were thinking about
doing it if that is a real thing that
can be proven on paper oh that's where
the conversation gets interesting
because when you start thinking about
and they mention this when you think
about the agreements that are in place
those are in direct contradiction to
legal documents and agreements between
these two uh these two different uh
countries as to how they do business
with one another that could get very
very sticky again it's
something if somebody wants to keep
pulling on that threat right if they
want to continue to go this route so you
should have never snitched
you open your mouth now we gotta close
it
it's your best verse you've ever spent
ever just wait yeah wait
if these deals come out it is going to
depend on how messy I get if it goes out
there I'm going to be messy regardless
oh I know it's near and dear to you
there's there's levels to this messiness
if they come out there you know they it
was proven that you know some of these
are time gated or completely lobbied off
of the Xbox platform
there's a level to that then there's
level above that where they've
specifically came out and said it can't
go on Xbox it's all over that and then
there's one above that says it can't
come to the platform ever and then
there's a point of that it says where
it's blocking Game Pass there's levels
to this and it's going to be magnificent
when I get that I will say this if any
of that happens which would be justified
because I know you've you've very
passionate about Japanese games on Xbox
what would be interesting if any of that
is part of the reasons as to why
platform get missed right and we always
we say like this doesn't mix I got you
okay but this doesn't make sense how do
they get this one but they don't get
this one and like just weird
inconsistencies with the platform I'm
not saying that they're bad traveler
okay you're going I can't I know you
ready yeah I'm just saying I'm just
saying
this is how I vote for somebody for
re-election oh Lord because well now
you're on fire right now I'm gonna tell
you right now I ain't never been a fan
right but for this yeah once I saw
Microsoft had you know you know ties to
my man Byron
yo if Byron's knuckle game is crazy so
if I run you would even like if yo you
know how the papers work comes out and
they'd be like yeah we just found out
here here
Byron talks about it yeah you know we
looked into that situation that was
happening with the APK I thought that
was wrong my man was trying to make a
deal over there and we also found that
it was corruption in this area Japan
said now prove that deal
because we had nothing to do with what's
going on over here that was the response
they absolved themselves from there just
check them because you know Byron picked
up the phone was like yo yeah how you
how y'all looking over there with
Microsoft um what the ABK deal it was
like they got a deal going on don't
don't play with me sir
I got a deal over there how you feel
about that do we need to looking yo
remember that what you owe listen let
that deal go through we ain't got no
problems with you yo um
we we had heard they was doing some
other stuff
send that over to the office Bing Bong
we good all right no doubt Byron
right now I know y'all
I know these Sony dudes is upset I know
y'all feel right now oh man how can we
stop King you can't stop me right now I
got Byron behind me you don't even care
about politics like that I don't care
about that as soon as they got the Xbox
and it's in your favor here you come by
imagine you snitching and a dude called
the president
no I'm not talking about I'm talking
about the prince
imagine you snitching and the dude
called the president of the Free Will
and look into you
know what type of clout does that dude
that you messing with this is when your
money was wrong and you should have shut
up
I'm so happy they called Byron on this
the Byron is on you son and now once
Japan once Japan knew that Byron was in
the deal hey yo ABK let that go big bro
challenge
King loves Byron as much as you love
mixes yeah you always
listen Byron and nixes is my heart I
gotta break product called Dick and J
member for 20 months
this man is too much man oh man I think
he definitely with the boot on the deck
with this but yeah I think that's a good
transition if we can move on to the
second part which is kids which we
wanted to talk about briefly Last of Us
PC Port oh man yeah um looks like a lot
of issues
um 37 only 37 percent other reviews are
positive so yeah basically
um it's mostly all negative overall
mostly negative on it uh problems with
stability overall performance and um
yeah the list goes long details of
unknown errors even people with high
fidelity uh cards older graphic cards
leads to instability
um degraded shaders potential memory
League Mouse and Camera Jitter game may
be unable to boot this this is really
really getting bad looks like Naughty
Dog Yo style I didn't know there was a
black face Joe oh yo that's why I just
see that right now I didn't even see it
yeah that's crazy
um like I said Remember on when they
launched the last of us uh PC on PC they
basically broke for any everyone so look
I don't know the dog has come out in
front and and try to make a statement I
believe there is a patch of at least the
first patch for it but there's still a
bear uh you know every of issues so King
uh where are you at this is not your
peoples this is not um this is iron
Galaxy I believe so your thoughts on the
last of SPC
shows me that Sony don't know what
they're doing
you you got Nexus in the and right now
Nexus is overworked they'll let you know
what an important uh IP as The Last of
Us uh they handed it over to uh uh iron
Galaxy yeah galaxy was an iron Galaxy is
purchased by uh what's these dudes no
they went they went no they went um they
went independent they've been
independent really they worked on Killer
Instinct they didn't kill anything but
then then Amazon and one of them
purchased them and then they let them go
out of their contract because they
didn't make the game that they were
supposed to make whatever hey I'll look
it up yeah so all right so they took
over and they did that uh Nick says I
know probably they hit Nixon so please
fix this but all the titles is coming
over to the PC at some point in time but
this is the master race this is the
problem with the master race this is the
problem that we have right
um PlayStation runs it fine
right right so you got these dudes over
there that's pointing it over my thing
was who the hell was in charge of
quality control who pushed the button
and said now this is good to go you only
tested it on your PC you was dancing in
the movies in the mirror to yourself you
didn't call your friend and say yo
check oh check this over and make sure
that it works on your PC at least with
five or six people verify that the game
works
it seems like they just said okay it ran
good for me and let's push this out to
the world
and that's not cool on on you got this
is the first time a lot of PC dudes
would ever got a chance to play The Last
of Us and you would turn these people
off from this franchise that is really
good it's a really good franchise but if
the first time you go to boot it up your
game don't work or your game is crashing
and you're running uh whatever 40 90
whatever the hell the highest card is
and your PC still can't play it then
that really means it's down to the
developers and not Sony I'm not going to
hang this on Sony's head I'm gonna hang
it on the fact that they farmed it out
to somebody else and then didn't keep
that in-house and they was trying to
capitalize on rushing it out the door
with the last of us to get those dollars
and I I think that hurt them it really
hurt the perception of the franchise
okay let me ask you to follow up do you
think I was gonna ask you that question
you answered but do you think that
because of the pressure of the show and
getting the Zeitgeist and getting it out
probably in that window do you think
they knew the condition of how this game
was going in and it was a deal it will
deal with it later situation yeah we're
in a generation now we're always in a
patch and fix it you probably didn't
know all the troubles right you probably
know about a couple of them but you you
remember the PC market is so Diversified
from the lowest and to the highest end
then you have to figure out all
in-betweens
if you saw one error on the stuff that
you was running
and then you didn't account for all the
errors that you would see just to make
it in that time frame or to get
while the the you know because a lot of
times people let all the shows come out
first and then binge watch it
the game comes out at the binge watch
moment those numbers is up now you want
to get that audience that uh might not
have a PlayStation
I think I think it was rush to the
market and I think you didn't care about
the consumer yes
attic PC Master race let's see Zelda
attic oh my God he keeps changing I
think he's have to wait for a little bit
so he'll be back but I'll get solved so
I've been what do you think about this
you are the master race this is what's
going on man you're not gonna be able to
run this one yeah
it's just weird man it's just weird that
I agree with King 100 is like at this
point you know the last of us is has the
name of it has has sort of proliferated
more and now it's known in other circles
now right and now it's it's revered in
other circles now and people will never
have or would touch the game so this is
just that other step of like hey I'm
gonna pass it on there are PC Gamers out
there who never in their life will buy a
PlayStation they will wait forever and
if it doesn't come to the platform it
doesn't come to the platform and now
they've finally got this game on with
this game this revered game 10 out of
10. the greatest narrative ever like it
you know a lot of hyperbole but at the
same time it is warranted I love that
game and I would you know again I I
understand the hype around it so to see
it come to the PC finally in this state
buy a port Studio that has been known to
do good work I mean just recently I'm
looking at it right now hold on a second
I'm looking at it right now iron Galaxy
Wikipedia right
the most recent thing is the rumble
verse that they did of their own which
which had to be shut down because epic
didn't want to put any more money into
it and it's I mean I played Rumble verse
and that was it was fun as hell yeah it
was super it was really fun they just
made hey it might even find a a home on
Xbox we'll see it should have been on
Game Pass but this is what happened
shoot your um your shot for sure but
they took over Killer Instinct season
two and three those were bangers right
that's of their own accord stuff you're
gonna like the second season I didn't
like what they turned it into they
turned it into I I could I can't stand
it really um I like when they initially
launched it the the first Studio that
worked on it first I thought that state
efforts was fantastic they Gary of a
great Foundation these dudes came on and
they mucked it up messed it up and I
walked away from it it is not the same
game it don't play the same uh they
probably have extra legs to it but new I
do not like the studio at all and the
fact that you walk from one great
franchise to the next great franchise
I'm not supporting you at all and the
fact that I think you bounce from place
to place because you aren't good at all
you are bad sir
I can't say that I mean look they they
did The Impossible reporting Skyrim to
the switch oh and then
for what it was what it was to get that
on there to get that on there they just
finished Legacy of of Thieves the
Uncharted for Windows that's fine they
worked on Metroid Prime remastered along
with uh with retro right so I I
sincerely believe that this was one of
those things where it's like it's got to
get out sooner rather later Calvin was
in charge They delayed it already this
was this was the second release date
they had delayed it already so they knew
work needed to be done on it my beef
with it is just they were super
disingenuous about oh oh we're looking
into some issues you know exactly what
game you were putting out and exactly
the amount of work that needed to be put
into the game still um it was funny
because the same day it came out I was
listening to um Jeff gershman's podcast
and he had Dave Lang the founder of our
galaxy on it was talking about how uh
he's like yeah yeah you know our latest
thing is so yeah the game that we worked
on is coming out soon I don't I don't
remember if he specifically said it was
last of us but he's like the last thing
that we worked on it will be out soon or
or is just releasing now it didn't
really get too much into the
conversation after that and then
obviously the very next day was this
explosion of all this drama but
when I look at some of the memes coming
out of this game where Ellie looks
there's one where Joel is on a on a
horse and Ellie's on the horse as well
and Ellie looks you know when they um in
terminated two when they blew up Robert
Patrick and he was like he was all in
different directions like this that's
how Ellie looked oh no and it was like
there's another one where Ellie's just
spinning in the air like like no like
you see there's a lot of funny memes
coming out of it but again it's just sad
because you know how the PC Community
does when something happens like this
and I I this I do command there is no
Sony bump here the PC Community don't
care about this they're like if you
messed up you messed up I don't care who
you are right and they met they make and
feel it so how fixable this is I hope
that it's fixable and at some point you
know we have an Arkham Knight situation
where the game is fixed after some point
but um it's sad because they could have
really capitalized on the on on the the
fervor around the uh the the show yeah
and just kind of kept The Last of Us in
people's minds and this kind of it's
just solid for no reason because I
guarantee you I don't even know what
what the sales numbers were but I can
guarantee a lot of people probably went
in blindly was like I'm blind it's
blindly it's gonna be fine and to see
this happen you know how those refunds
go on Steve you know how that review
bombing goes on Steam like the PC
Community will make you pay so uh we'll
see I overall does it hurt the last of
us there you know because every again to
King's Point they're gonna be like oh
it's iron Galaxy it wasn't even nyx's
the in-house Studio it wasn't even
Naughty Dog the in-house Studio the
PlayStation version runs great because
Naughty Dog amazing
so yeah it's it's it's a sad thing I
don't know how much it affects it long
term maybe not that much if we see more
like this I mean I I honestly feel like
somebody's gonna be to blame for this I
don't know this all Iron Galaxy
I really I really don't I just think it
was somebody somebody in the suit was
like it gotta come out so let me put
pressure on him yeah yeah and I don't
care what y'all do Don't You Buck up on
me you make sure that that game come out
on time because let me tell you
something we put a lot of money into
this now we got to get that zeit guys
that's that's what shopping talks about
and sovereign
was really shocked by that
it could be ghosts that they're working
on right yeah I mean look at the end of
the day you know Chad is saying like you
know naughty dog got to get some some
blame too and that's valid I mean
especially with the fact that you know
they're kind of alluding I don't know if
you have a room between the line like
there's Synergy with PC as they continue
on this journey yes and we heard about
obviously factions and you know what I'm
saying most likely there the rumors also
PS4 PS5 potentially pspc
day one kind of situation naughty dog in
my opinion the verbiage the signals they
seem to be giving is that they are
getting close to synergizing day and
date releases
based on what the verbiage is again
people say I may be looking into it I'm
just going by what I see by The Feelers
they've given up they keep talking about
this Synergy with PC you know and and
their major releases so now it just
comes down to like how does this happen
with your Flagship right how did this
happen and in Iron Galaxy defense I
gotta defend a little bit you know yeah
maybe they handle the port but if there
was a scenario like you were saying
software up top or can you say up top is
saying this needs to happen that this
time frame right
who knows who knows who knows if that
that was undue pressure on iron Galaxy
and and it came from up top we don't
know 100 but there has to be
accountability on both sides like this
is this is The Last of Us bro like this
is you creme de La Creme this is what
got people into gaming and I get it you
have this hit show but you like like you
said something the the PC Community
ain't trying to hear none of that they
are not going to there's not going to be
any passes there's not going to be and
it's a shame because it shouldn't have
to be that way this really looks bad
this really looks bad like when I saw
the blackface Joel thing I'm like bro
what is going on AI situation look crazy
you know we got to see we got to see
what's going to happen how they correct
it I mean a quarter shot to cast out of
using it he said I guess the latest
patch he said it does play a little bit
better but what sucks is there's so many
people the beauty of them putting their
games on PC is that there's going to be
so many people that's going to try their
experiences for the first first time
this is their first time and that's
their experience this
if the Horizon one port if I remember I
don't know if it was our galaxy
but the Horizon one I heard was issues a
little bit at one point they were there
at launch same with like I guess was it
wasn't God of War I think God of War was
smooth but I think days gone had issues
at launch as well uh let me see let me
see Horizon PC Port yeah I'm very I
remember the PC songs about PC gang let
me know Master is yelling there if you
if y'all if I'm bugging on that one
because I could have sworn there was
some issues there but look they've got
to get this right especially with their
plan to synergize and to King's Point
yeah they got to do this right they
can't play around this is money on the
table extra money just for existing
Port it over right take the time you
need to do this thing right so yeah and
shout out to Nixon yeah
yeah shout out the Nexus but uh yeah it
was broken zero Dawn was broken at
launch I didn't remember that let me see
who you remember
yeah who was the who was the deaf okay
let's find out it's them again let's
find out it's them I don't know there's
a PC Port developer it was gorilla okay
well there it is we know gorilla don't
know that yeah and like I said it would
be a shame but anyway that's what I got
on this super chats and then final time
okay and let's get to this final Time
come on hold on okay let me
we got hold on a second session
okay I got a lot of Joe Byron
oh Lord all right we got Louis just
Augustus member for 19 months Lord
bronze Japanese games that come to Xbox
in the west and have Japanese language
support in the west that game isn't on
the Xbox in Japan why would that be
yes
things things
there we go Stitch remember for 40
months Lord gold thank you all I want is
crash in front of the Sony building
calling out Sackboy [__] your dude is a
snitch
yeah that's crazy
we got clutch man five dollar super chat
if they investigate the Japanese Market
somebody's gonna be hurting worse than a
prostate exam by Mandingo
yo dudes get created
then we got Jay's Jay surge 12 two
dollar Super Chat Sony really chedded
Bob themselves
yeah remember that yo you have to shoot
yourself Jake there we got Tony Bryant
remember for 30 bucks Lord gold Joe
Byron woke up and chose violence on a
serious note Sony seriously now will
have eyes on any desks on any desk they
make on anything
yeah and we got puckish Rogue one
hundred two dollar Super Chat is Sony
gonna catch heat for their cross play
attacks yeah they did they fixed that I
think they call heat for that already
dude
yeah I don't know if they addressed it
but they definitely call he for it
so we got Robert kellett yeah
Robert Kelly two dollar Super Chat Joe
Byron someone cry station for Last of Us
pc4
if the words Last of Us pc4 come out of
that man's mouth I would die right wow
you know especially at that point then
we got Stitch remember for two years two
dollar Super Chat what do you all think
is going to happen with the FTC
I didn't think they might be some
posturing But ultimately I think we'll
need to come like a deck of cards you're
gonna have to continue
the concessions come before the deadline
right get it out or they still play the
game where they're gonna fight Microsoft
approves the deal on himself anyway he
wants to eat you and all that stuff is
done and then they said go take us to
court and see what if you're gonna stop
there that's that's my Envision one of
the two scenarios but it my vibe it's
going through that's the vibe I get
then we got Garcia this Garcia ten
dollars
just Garcia I've said it before and I'll
say it again it's only it's looking like
O.J Simpson in the opening scene of
naked gun for all you youngsters Google
it love your show I don't even remember
the scene I know well yeah wasn't he
like brainwashed or something no that
wasn't the opening thing
then we got natey nay five dollar Super
Chat The Regulators asked Sony what
y'all scared of and Sony handed their
own documents and said this is what was
scared of
wow messy then we got doobie remember
for 27 months Lord bronze could another
reason Sony's opposing is opposing to
the Activision Blizzard deal because of
the contracts they had with Destiny and
Call of Duty them boys are scared
hashtag IOP bookofx
Saloon salute then we have bean dip nip
slip
[Laughter]
that's why I like that I like that
that's wow
that's different that's different five
dollars
tears of the Kingdom looks like DLC save
assets also [__] yo don't say masses and
Ragnarok look fire absolutely
you got nasty nay once again five dollar
Super Chat Microsoft telling Sony now
Microsoft telling Sony we're about to
fill up on you
I don't know
whoa assistant
I don't like that context continue that
we got Joe Repco AKA play member for two
years five dollars for chat Brad Smith
to Jim Ryan Jim do you remember the
story of Julius Caesar Phil said it once
and I'll say it again stop teasing us
bro
Sony don't have no single player games
they had to drop it sure
then we have NC ghost of low road two
dollar Super Chat okay send you a
hellblade Ninja Theory motion captured
dead
okay
look alive to me really alive and we got
Carl Andrews Jr 2010 I beat the last of
us on PS3 and four I've moved on and no
need to play it again I get that too
wait for the price drop
yes sir big price drop yeah
uh let me see hold on a second
tychosaurus okay tiger sorry 15 Super
Chat King Captain for naughty dog right
now it was either them because of their
first port for my knowledge or it's Sony
wanting to rush it out for the show
great show Lords but King's wrong on
this one okay you know what I told you
they rusted out for this
oh he's saying the blame on iron Galaxy
listen I ain't got again they developed
it right so they have to take the blame
but the thing about it is like it's one
of those things where if I'm on Galaxy
I'm not taking that L with y'all bro I'm
be like they forced us because the iron
Galaxy this is their bread and butter
this is what they this is like if if
their name goes to to the toilet they're
in trouble we tell us yeah I tell I'd be
like listen man this happened this to
happen I'm not eating that pause
[Laughter]
Carl Andrews Jr once again 2010 I love
the last of us it's time to move on to
three yes three which is what I think
they're gonna be working on I don't
think it's a new thing
bean dip nip slit yeah
I know I was late on this other topic
just wanted to throw shade uh tears of
the Kingdom looks mid to me too just
like Ragnarok was expecting the same for
Spider-Man 2 Jesus
then we got Lord Metroid two dollars to
protect yeah I mean you spent Millions
on these engines and they can only use
it one time
golf God forbid God forbid
Lord Metroid 2000 Super Chat The Last of
Us is like NyQuil it will put you to
sleep damn oh come on damn
cold let's go
yeah that's it we're caught up all right
[Music]
sales off you got this
so I mean first things first is the the
psvr tube has apparently underperformed
ah
oh yeah and where's King where where's
King going dude
[Laughter]
yo and don't do all the stuff that Jeff
joint do but you know what it do do that
you can't do
yo the best part of it is I'm so happy
uh-huh all right and dudes is like no I
can't you know you know we out here you
know cause they doing VR for you no
they're not the VR for me is right here
oh man yo and all because you know it
has a 4K you know what you don't have
untethered
when you cut your wire then you're gonna
see those numbers go higher
but what happened to all those dudes
that was capping none of y'all showed me
y'all had a console it's like four Dudes
they need more people Jim said y'all not
enough you not enough
let's go you messy man oh man can you
not have said it better myself though
like I said as as a day one adapter psvr
too I don't really care about the
narrative about where whether it's doing
well or not except for in the context of
my issues up front what it was
a brand new piece of of Hardware that is
an accessory to another Hardware
expected to perform in a closed off
ecosystem when on the opposite side end
of the spectrum the same type of
hardware and the PC ecosystem is
the things you can experiment with in VR
on the PC is Bonkers like just stupid
things but at the same time that's what
makes it fun and exciting whereas in a
closed ecosystem what I was hoping for
is the support from Sony first party
second party to really elevate it right
and give me more whatever core games or
things that are closer to core games and
not the experimental stuff and my worry
with this right with the numbers being
as low as it is where the assumption is
that they've sold somewhere around 270
000 units
[Music]
and that is not nearly
I mean when we heard the rumors about
them cutting the the initial shipments
they kind of stayed quiet about it they
didn't say anything
and you know that even that one million
sounds like it was it was it was it was
still alive
it's one of those things where it's like
is this the next Vita is this the next
thing because of how slow it is out of
the gate
do we get kind of Nintendo I'm not sorry
a PlayStation turned into cheek and be
like yeah so this ps6 you know like and
we don't see the support that I was
hoping to get
um there's other speculation or that
obviously we should see a piece a price
drop soon
um and I go back when I think about this
this quick price drop I think about the
pivot that Nintendo had to make with the
3DS 3DS came out it was wild expensive
crazy expensive and within a couple of
months because the sales weren't where
it needed to be
they had to drop the price give us uh
the ambassador program made a couple of
free games for the people that were
early adopters and then obviously the
story of the 3DS turned around this is
different in that Nintendo really needed
to do that because I was just their
mobile platform they needed to get this
Sony may look at this like look we made
the investment it is what it is
let's mostly cut our losses and we're
not gonna We're Not Gonna Elevate the
status of the platform Beyond ports and
things of that nature which is to me
this would be disappointing and and
scary as a day one adopter
um one of the other arguments that I
heard around this besides the obvious
ones where it's like it's more expensive
than the actual console itself in a time
where inflation is crazy and people you
know jobs are getting cut you're
expecting people to pay climate premium
a super premium for an accessory that
that needs another base console to
function right beyond all of that stuff
one argument that I didn't quite
understand and maybe you could Cog you
could sort of clarify on this what's up
there was an argument indicating that
because the quote unquote the metaverse
concept is failing or whatever the case
may be that for whatever reason this you
can attribute this sort of quote-unquote
failure of the psvr to at least
initially to some of that that concept
like not being as big as people were
hoping it is and I don't know that the
the metaverse stuff especially when when
you think about Sony and the PlayStation
VR and the closed ecosystem I don't know
that was ever a big consideration for
that right that's a good point that's a
good point I mean In fairness I was
taking a tour of the company line here
but In fairness you know I don't feel
that they marketed themselves in that
way in that way at all so for me which
is disheartening because I'm pulling for
them right you know at the end of the
day Sony VR doing well makes quests more
attractive you know cross-playing and
stuff like that so make no mistake you
know it's the first time I'm gonna throw
a couple land but made no mistake like
we're playing for each other right you
you don't want because if they succeed
then it makes VR bigger right yeah and
them not then you know and having kind
of a small stutter out the gate how can
I jump in if you're here unless you yeah
just real quick to me the thing about it
is one thing to consider also is that
this VR VR2
comes into the market in a different
very different place for VR right when
the first psvr2 came into the market it
was very much still like okay we got the
pcvr that's ridiculously expensive now
this is this is this is the option for
the common man and you associate it with
the PlayStation branded in the PS4
generation was just up here Sky High and
it felt like it was in every position to
succeed and you know they sold over 5
million units that's a success for that
type of peripheral it is a completely
different landscape right now yeah and
for it to come in at that price point
with lack of like games that really show
it off and a lot of ports and stuff like
that I just don't think it it's pushing
the narrative in the way you would hold
PlayStation would be able to take that
ball and run with it
um so I yeah it's got an uphill battle
for sure
yeah this is this is tough two Vibes
yeah and looking like somebody stepping
on a rake Vibes
look this is definitely you know tough
on VR right now we just got to be
completely transparent you know the
price point the economic climate you
know it's a King's Point I got to give
them his flowers he called this he's he
we had this topic initially he said Cog
I'm sorry
you know I don't see you know it has a
true competitor or a threat you know and
me from a tech standpoint I'm always
curious on the advancement in the space
so I'm looking at from what as a VR now
gamer right what you offered I'm like yo
this is really cool Tech I like that I
went to King's Point yes I am biased and
it says I don't like a tethered
experience but one of the trade-offs
would tell that is higher Fidelity you
know what I mean get dollars though I
get it I think the thing comes down to
you know the combination of multiple
things it's the price point and to some
of you said it best I think you know one
of the things I look at is the fact that
it is Tethered to a PS5 at the end of
the day to have like which king always
said you have to have that device and
then you have the second device and I
don't know in this climate you know is
that something interesting and a big
part of that is if they can figure out a
way to integrate with PC because at the
end of the day closing off that
ecosystem does hurt like you said solve
this it's a lot of creative things you
know that you can do I mean even with
requests you know you can collect that
to a PC I can play Half-Life Alex you
could do a wirelessly I could do a
wirelessly through air League I could do
again you open up the ecosystem you open
up and get more creators and stuff in
there so it's up to them to try to
figure this out I I expect them to
course correct quickly I expect them to
I think so
I'm not I'm not saying how much impact
it's going to have but this is what is
the 200 they had projections on I think
about 2 million yeah right and then they
flashed that to 1 million right and then
they probably remember they tried to
come at the guy yeah who put out the
report to say it was false a thousand
numbers look like it is even worse it's
worse right so now it comes down to what
is it 270 000. that that's that's a
that's a DOA kind of numbers and and I
have well no facts and facts like if you
had certain projections you get that yes
but I had one dude on my timeline
and um anybody that can go on my
timeline right now you know my Twitter's
open and I follow everybody who follows
me
um you can go on my timeline you can see
that one guy that was Captain crazy hard
not is this a success 270
000 is a success they did in in the VR
space is a success
and I'm like okay uh where's your VR he
didn't even have one oh damn I'm like
bro shut up and sit down I mean you can
love a console all you like but stop
capping for something you don't have now
I'm going to talk from a perspective of
owning and not owning right right not
owning they didn't show me anything that
I needed to do other than the climbing
simulator boom soda climbing simulator
I'm like I don't think that's gonna get
everybody into the door the fact that is
a lot of dudes are still holding onto
their PlayStation 4 because they didn't
see the reason to jump over to the
PlayStation 5 yet because uh Jim
stated majority of their games is going
to be cross-platform regardless so
there's no true reason to jump over yet
now those individuals that's probably
sitting on the fence will have to get if
if they want the PlayStation VR2 they
will have to get a PlayStation 5. and if
those dudes have a PlayStation 5
and you purchase the PlayStation uh one
VR
you had all those games that are not
compatible with the PlayStation 2 VR
we've learned this lesson
if you don't bring your catalog that
people have invested in the past forward
there's a reluctancy in uh continuing to
support that console the next console
that comes out the next iteration of set
console I think they did this off a
disservice with the previous five
million owners
yeah
gravitated over to me they lost hundreds
of thousands of sales with that right
that's a good point we can't we can't
ignore it you know what I'm saying at
the end of the day that that that that
compatibility and moving and bringing a
baseball especially when they were kind
of trying to establish that look they've
got they got they got an uphill battle
on that I'm curious to see how they try
to cross correct I by guess probably
price reduction I'm curious to see what
they do yeah
but this is some I guess my concern is
just that you know as a person who
followed a ton of PlayStation
peripherals uh kid we've had this talk
where my my fear is when it doesn't go
well out the gate just leave it alone
they run away from it yeah I'm a I'm a
PSP guy I'm a leader guy like my
Journey's still over there yeah I got I
got three of them upstairs
I'm about that life bro like I'm day one
it's to me still does things that the
Nintendo switch still can't do and do
you know what I'm saying like don't get
me wrong I support so it's just like it
bothers me because I'm like man I don't
want them to run away from this joint
like I wanna I'm curious to see if
there's going to be a double down
commitment and I guess the reason why it
bothers me is because I know you call it
the climbing simulator but what excited
me about the VR with them is I look at
attic addict is the test bed for me
right add it goes [__] I love quests
whatever whatever but I want those big
games too demio was fired but I want
like again the just one the Triple A or
whatever it is in that type of I'm like
if anybody could do that
yeah Sony you know what I'm saying so
that's what I'm very curious to see you
know how they respond to it but yeah
it's unfortunate we'll see what happens
but I did want to bring up because you
know as king says I got to provide
ballots balance PlayStation 5 have one
of the most massive sales Buffs ever
King did you hear oh my God yes I do oh
my God I heard I heard they February
legendary I heard that on Pace to equal
the PlayStation 4. I heard crazy history
yo nuts nuts right
always looks over to them and says you
still ain't enough like you gonna reach
that magical number of 110 or 112
million you always reach this you've
always reached the president you have
always reached the Mountaintop imagine
you climbing in Mount Everest and you
got up there and you you planting your
flag and it do look over to you and say
you still ain't enough yo Y'all Gonna
keep hitting that ceiling whoa right
right y'all gonna keep hitting it it
ain't no champion this is you ain't
championing nothing don't wave your arms
in the air talking about a fantastic
February your February is gonna equal
nothing yet again yo you know what your
February
no yo your February looks like me when I
was winning all those games and I was
going against bots that's that's what
your February looks like your February
looks like you ain't accomplishing
nothing because at the end it's gonna be
the same result and he gonna look over
to you and say you not enough we need
200 million where's the others so if you
went double and triple that month show
me something better but what's gonna
happen you still ain't getting a
PlayStation 6. I don't care what you do
I was gonna see you still holding on
what I see you're gonna reach that 110
and you're gonna spread out and nobody
else gonna buy I know what's gonna
happen y'all ain't enough same dudes not
enough huh
that's shaking you a little bit too
because I think I just gonna bring him
down from 96 to about 90 kill us off
after this one you're gonna regret this
way
station forever the whole place
and y'all gonna tell me your king but we
still got a PlayStation 5. yeah you
gonna be an app cause you not enough
they need you all over the place they
don't need you in the why do we keep
selling to the same fools the same
Fool's gonna keep buying ain't nothing
different ain't nobody knew walking to
the ecosystem you the same dude I see
nobody knew what my timeline talk about
hey man I'm part of the new PlayStation
Clan no you not you the same dude
you're just like me ain't nothing
different I got one you got one I had
one last time too you know what he told
me I wasn't enough not impressed though
not impressed not impressive the
greatest PlayStation sales but for the
history of history and and Microsoft is
still making the same money tell me
what's up tell me what's up buddy oh you
saw the Buddy talking about okay
we're talking about the direct
competition
okay but what happened once Byron on the
case
tell me what they do next month
so I'm gonna let you finish out with
your thoughts are dead obviously
Resident Evil where did we get about it
yeah yeah PS I'm again this is this is
their Lane this is where they're going
to continue to be successful and it's at
this point to use a column Moriarty term
it's inertia like it really is like the
PlayStation trade is kind of hard to
stop like uh even when they deserve to
smoke right um but again it just is what
it is and this is where they to me
we'll see what happens with VR we'll see
what happens with them in any sort of
peripheral in the future
um but I do think this is what they
focus on what focus is right and
continuing to provide those experiences
that they're known for it's going to be
interesting though because obviously you
know a lot of people finally getting
their hands on PlayStations right and I
think more than ever we're going to
start seeing a PlayStation that changes
a little bit we will get those single
player games generation refresh I heard
mid-jen refreshed it which supposedly we
might be hearing about this week even
our new Sony conference on King ahead
yeah it's not bothering me they
that's another PlayStation 6. I feel
that way they not bothering me they're
gonna they can make 40 of these
different systems I don't care they can
make a slim they can make a double
decker they can make a uh
they could make an XL they could do what
yeah bro the pro was definitely a double
decker
cheeseburger I can't stand is King
jumping out the window we have to wait
so long for him to be wrong
slowly slowly
listen Mr O Mr O please
be quiet
no your shirt say Mr
ohiders taking your knees
I love the fact that we got the new
reluctant fighter
anyway I don't want to show up to other
matches
you ain't gonna go over two hours
the Resident Evil Zero stands for the
amount of times you beat me in Fighters
over there
I slaughtered you all across the place
there you go so yes resevil 4.
I long live the Remake it's the remakes
are eating out here yeah shout out to
Dead Space shout out to Resident Evil
for res Evil 4 in two days she sold over
3 million copies she's a hype is real
for context the original Resident Evil 4
on GameCube sold 1.4 million in its
entire lifetime wow boy the Wii version
and PS2 version together no it's not
together we sold 2 million 2.3 on the
PlayStation 2. think about how many
PlayStation 2s out there yep
mind you residual Force pretty much
everywhere right PC Xbox PlayStation not
switch so not not everywhere
three million units
the hype for this game is one of those
games that
you couldn't you could not hope for the
game to live up to the hype and then it
did right and then they were they you
know the fans reciprocated and kind with
the numbers like I would never thought
in a million years we get a 3 million
seller in two days
that's I kind of I kind of thought it
would because
um
what Resident Evil 4 meant when it came
out and how it changed the Resident Evil
formula you know change it changed the
action game formula period yeah it it it
it it it changed uh how we viewed
Resident Evil the same way seven changed
how we view Resident Evil now right they
always have these little changes and you
know one to three was really good but
full on that GameCube
I don't care what anybody said that made
the GameCube a place to go like if if
them securing that meant a lot because
remember the first demo that we saw
remember that was two different games it
made people it made people block by a
GameCube straight up just for that game
yeah they changed it because the first
one looked like Resident Evil 3. and it
looked like more of the same
they chopped that went with the the
behind that little angle that he has the
Sherman and all that stuff yeah yeah
they changed it was even the locales was
different you don't remember that demo
in my room or did it start did it start
off as the Devil May Cry again
um I think the character models they
were looking at it that way and then
that's how they spent off with Devil May
Cry because remember Dante looks more
like Leon yeah like as far as in some
ways yeah knowledge and and like
superhero type of feel Leon was the
first
hero because yeah we we had the other
heroes from the previous games right but
they didn't feel like it yeah there was
Marines and stuff like a little secret
agent going to get the president's
daughter had to Snick cut to Sherling
yeah the mountains you know it the first
time you shot a knife that was thrown at
you yeah you shot it you shot it out of
their hand the shirt to me I remember us
we lost our mind because the Sherling
looked like a Shirley for real you could
tell the leather texture on this on the
coat oh my God yeah the cat was it the
Capcom five
the concept overall did it did except
for like Beautiful Joe in this game I
don't know everything else that really
popped like that
um but uh oh and then killer seven I
think
um
but yeah man uh it's kind of crazy it's
kind of I just to me I just wanted to
point it out because res evil this
Renaissance of Resident Evil and just
horror games in general is I love horror
games and I went when done right you
know it's been done right there it's
special because it for you to take
something that you have agency in and
still terrified grown men and adults
like it's special and Resident four was
special than that it was a time and
place thing where it reset the
expectations for Resident Evil but it
also reset the expectations for the
action genre right you have you have you
know things like you know kill switch
obviously gears all of the third the the
template for the third person action
game came from this yes
um so it's a special game and the fact
that they were able to do it justice do
the original Justice and they still
improve upon it which is something
that's very difficult to do
um it is special so I'm excited to keep
playing it I'm getting smoked right now
by all of these gonados but uh I'm
enjoying it shout out to Capcom res evil
yeah it's crazy they did it again Lord
addict that already forged your goat you
see the numbers are crazy how you
feeling about it
it makes sense you know I would say
resume before is one of like
the pillars of gaming people really give
it a lot of clout I unfortunately
haven't been able to play it yet uh I
had to prioritize certain things with
life and the thing I thought was gonna
get it for ended up falling through to
me so you know I get it eventually but
I'm always enjoying it you know resident
before is one of my all-time favorite
games and I feel like it gets a lot of
hate for the wrong reasons like it gets
hate because it's not Resident Evil 2.
yeah and you know it's kind of like the
Resident Evil 6 I mean Final Fantasy six
versus seven like they're both great
games but people have a hard time not
putting a flag on one of them so yeah I
think the Remake the the success of
Resident Evil 2 remake green lit this
one I think they don't touch resident
before if two remake doesn't do what it
did yeah two different they took it they
took it I mean not too big a risk but
yeah I mean it's a beloved game that
they remade and yeah you've seen the
success King where you at right I'm
sorry
I was saying capcom's continuously
proven that like look people will buy
these older games just gotta do them
right correct if you want to pop in and
just do the bare minimum you're gonna
get the bare minimum in terms of
financial support but if you come in
there and you show people that you care
about the franchise that they love and
they remember and you redo it in a way
that makes sense and you don't spit in
the the fans of the people who made that
game what it is they'll show up in
droves to buy that and Resident Evil
four show that was Evil 2 showed that
and I I'm glad that they did it because
it's pretty much at this point it's come
industry standards if you want to do a
remake of something for it these are the
standards don't do these you're not
going to have that kind of support
salute to them the care that they took
with it little kid Resident Evil
Sherling season the numbers is out
well
I mean the smartest thing that you know
Resident Evil did what Capcom did was
when they did do the remake of Resident
Evil 2 uh they already had an
established template of a great story
and a framework right so all you had to
do was go in there uh pretty it up fix
up a couple of things and retell the
story in a different narrative way and
and to go and get the old crowd and to
appeal to the new crowd and the old
crowd is always going to support we're
always going to support it yes so we go
back we support because we had those
same feelings and now that you put a
Twist on it we're not playing the same
exact thing we're playing something a
little bit different but it's familiar
at the same time so when you see it uh
seeing him like y'all remember that but
it was a little bit different and you
can have that conversation around it and
then let's say if attic never played uh
two from the beginning he comes and
plays the Remake he's like yo this is
incredible he has the same great story
with the same great structure told in a
way that's new for him with all the
bells and whistles so it appeals to both
crowds you going on both sides the
Resident Evil 4 doesn't shock me because
they continue the same Trend I want to
know if they're going to do a Resident
Evil 5 uh because those Graphics was a
little bit updated and Resident Evil 6
before they get to you know uh Resident
Evil 7 doesn't need and Resolute
Resident Evil 8 don't need it at all uh
how they how do they attack those games
with the success of this because you
can't stop right you can't stop at four
or is a success what you want next you
want five next you need five
um as much as I love five
and it's just like it deserves
it's weird that you played the the
remake of one and it's not the Resident
Evil 2 Resident Evil 4 Resident Evil 3
uh treatment it's like to me that's a
spit in that game's face because that's
what started it all I mean yeah but it
was before it was that that first go
around that remix and that's a great
remake but it's very much in the old
vein I think they remake one
for current gen consoles only
and maximize both consoles to their
height
to make you to to to change that how
that definitely consisted you felt that
they they spit in in the face of the uh
the fans
I feel like giving two three and four
that kind of treatment most likely five
it's weird that the original one doesn't
have that treatment like one would have
think it should have started there and I
think that you know after they saw the
reception of Resident Evil one it led to
them going this hard for the rest but
it's just like you need to go ahead and
just go back and do it I love five and I
think if they do six they just redo that
game entirely like Resident Evil 6
reimagine remake clay
I mean five is is I would say it's
controversial but people feel like five
does need it and it'll be good but
Veronica I love that orange Dreamcast
that's one of the most honest so many
people have it yeah you know what I mean
anyway because it was kind of locked to
that platform for a while it was the
first with true 3D environment it's like
it was yeah it was still in that same
vein with the pre you know with the
pre-canned camera angles but everything
was polygons instead of pre-rendered I
would love to see it I think when it
comes to Resident Evil you know it's a
it's a very beloved franchise and I
think Capcom you know you can argue
about Resident Evil 2 and 3 we wouldn't
get that Dead Space remake and I think
that you know stuff like that you know I
would give Final Fantasy maybe Final
Fantasy started it maybe with the amount
of love that seven remake got uh that
led to them entertaining the ideal to
remake Resident Evil 2 the way they did
I I it's hard to tell we don't know
what's happening like behind the closed
doors when they both were being
developed we don't know which one came
first you know res Final Fantasy VII may
have been uh the Remake might have been
old and announced a long time ago but we
don't know exactly when that full
production started so I just I like this
you know a lot of people they don't like
games getting remade I'm I'm on the
opposite I'm like you know if you do it
right okay do it this way
right then go to a new IP and people be
acting like we get Banger new IPS
sometimes it's okay for me to play
something I know I'm gonna love that's
reimagined in a very unique way then to
just take a gamble on something I might
not and this is the thing the gamble is
the operative word these big companies
no matter how much money they have they
don't like taking gambles on new IP if
it's not gonna if they're not guaranteed
success it's tough it's tough for new
IPS out there so yeah they're going to
go back to the well I'm gonna go back to
the well with everything they got
until hold on I gotta address something
oh uh Jake James logo you call Cog is
saying that
he wanted to correct you want the
correct credit yeah yeah yeah but not a
big restaurant Vibes
yeah so tell me you watched but I'll
watch them but you probably listening
but me and Cog don't sound the same
right now so you can fix it we got to
fix the Tweet get the credit he was like
one of the black guys said that yeah
I love it
I mean the market is going to show you
know what it is and they clearly like
addict said if people do it right then
they're gonna come there in droves and
I'm not gonna say it's low lift but it's
definitely lower than making a new IP
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah this
game is expensive it's very risky
business man these games flop but that's
what I got anything else before we get
up out of here in this Marathon that we
did yeah it's ridiculous
and was playing Oculus for a little bit
Yeah Super Shots are here they're quick
I got him right now let me see it
Joe Repco AKA flame member for two years
we chat to King's credit he actually
bought the psvr 2 kudos
that we you know not the two the psvr
one yeah
hey man my my guy is right here bro
that's my guy right here man I'm gonna
stick with the untethered tethering of
the situation man I'm not doing what you
doing now
there we got Daryl back to remember for
two years five dollars to be tapped did
King get that patent for bending knee
somebody got some pretty big knees all I
have the IOP salute the Lord's Day
resolution I call Joe Byron you know he
hooked me up with you know a little bend
the knee a metal I got a metal chill
fire I got a purple purple heart star
shut his mic he got a [__] it he's Wild
on him
then we got the Nintendo on the old Taco
five dollar Super Chat reform Metroid
Prime are the highest rated games of the
year goes to show that gaming hasn't
improved since the GameCube Nintendo the
goat we already knew this was coming wow
they feeling theyself right now
we got Jimmy B dancing
someone gift addict re4 it's crazy he
not played it he has it he just hasn't
played it man he has it he ain't played
I ain't got to get it oh
[Music]
I would like them to do zero and one as
a re part one and two yeah then do code
Veronica then five and six makes a nine
and ten in there between the remix also
please Dino Crisis I think yo they I
think they're gonna pop off a script if
they do zero zero the training bro I
remember like I Gotta Give GameCube that
fight like WPS that he was looking
different like they was yeah they had
some deals that's what I was playing my
game okay the GameCube was was the last
the last Nintendo console they had
parody with the other two people yeah
there was a fight the only thing is yo
if they didn't do the stupidness and
make those little mini discs yep and
they went with full disc oh yeah I don't
think the PlayStation would have
survived time I think the PlayStation
would have done like this
yeah yeah
he get to spit whole paragraphs yeah
with the recent cancellation of e3 how
do you think the games industry moves
forward in the subsequent years the
choices are hey don't call it a comeback
we pop and Esa will regroup with a
transformed version of e3 b game
Publishers will continue to do their own
events outside of e3 over the summer or
see I don't care just smoking on that E3
pack right now
those are the votes go put it up on
Twitter it'll be out there see what
y'all do good to be back y'all good to
be back talking to everybody get back
into the flow of podcasting we will get
all the technical stuff straightened out
we still got some issues we gotta fix
but I appreciate y'all rocking with us
through everything and appreciate
everybody that pulled up you know what
I'm saying especially at PAX East and
anybody on the street and took a picture
with us the love was felt salute to all
of the developers that we did interview
that showed that passion but uh yeah
let's get some outros Lord attic man
salute to you on the fine work as always
hooking us up in this look good and
putting the content some of the illest
thumbnails and just doing the thing man
and so what are you doing your first
interview
um facts too it's kind of dope we came
with people first shout out to Anchorman
because he's the one that gave me the
idea for those things absolute
second off you know I appreciate
everyone coming through you know we add
up to like almost 700 and some people in
here some change
you come through here man we we we we we
do what we can man we try to put up
entertainment you know what we've been
live for five hours and seven minutes
and you know hope you guys enjoyed every
minute of that it's like I said earlier
you know if you guys want to see some
some exclusive stuff on patreon
especially uh here recently here pretty
soon called reacting to some some music
that he probably ain't never heard y'all
definitely go over there uh sub to the
patreon man you know we'll give you guys
that that good good good content no
doubt salute to you keeping the patience
interesting and rocking everybody
pulling up Lord solved we're gonna find
people find what you got going on sir
back to work
hopefully trying to find some time to
play rezzy before but um yeah that's
pretty much where I'm at
without Lord King super messy but funny
as usual
Byron yo
um attic did the Arnold with the Lords
come out last week or what what are we
doing I've just been so busy I haven't
had time all right so it's gonna go all
right so check it out this RNR this
Tuesday is not going to be live uh
because it's uh my wife's birthday so
just put both of them together
we're going to give y'all a great
content that we got uh John Wick with
special guests uh host uh Lord Sovereign
yes yes and um we have the Shazam with
special guest uh Tyler uh so yeah man uh
we we did a lot of stuff at Pax we tried
to do as much as we possibly can
um first of all I'm gonna take my hat
off to my brother uh attic yes first of
all for being a bigger man right now I
just saw tremendous growth in you sir
and I take my my hat off to you I take
my hat off to you no what's wrong
behind the scenes we had certain things
and right now you came out you showed a
level of growth that you didn't even
have to do all right so I'll talk to you
about that later so uh nobody needs to
know that but I saw growth I saw growth
in a man that is one did his first
interview yes
and he he was like yo King man I want to
do this I'm ready for this I want to do
this all right no doubt let's go do it
um I'll walk them through it even though
he clowned me in later yeah because you
do the wrap it up beatboxing yeah yeah
you don't know wrap it up dude
you're five minutes
in 30 seconds you have to wrap it up
so but uh you know he he did his thing
um also he did his thing with uh getting
that content together right uh hoarding
all the content and and going through
the content putting the thumbs up and
thumbnails up and sending it to the site
one-man show one man army working as
hard as he possibly can all night taking
a flight early in the morning
yeah he's moving moving his whole life
you dudes a lot of you guys asked me to
be on your show
let's get it talk to it shame on you
content creators for always looking for
me and not looking for him facts
you know uh situation yeah like like my
man's uh uh opinions ain't validated it
ain't worthy uh like like he's not
charismatic enough or he doesn't bring
uh I gotta say though where I'm finally
starting to see they get my man is props
so I was the red four interview oh
because not only was that addict's idea
then we do it he ran the interview and
he interviewed us and Toby you get 100
honest yeah I got the whack version yeah
oh I messed up I messed up right
we had a version of that was so much
fired into what y'all got the one y'all
got is good but the one we had that yeah
technical we gonna get the technical
stuff out the way but yeah called it and
clicked the record oh you're not going
to talk about it's painful so it's you
just saw us talking and it looked like
we were mutes I deleted that I'm sure
I'm sure people that are deaf that can
read lips really good I'm sure you could
see that but no one else could shout out
to Lolly said the attic always support
GW exactly give my mans his flowers he
gets busy and like Saul was saying the
way he conducted that he's like yo I
think we should do this outside of what
we already did all right man he got he
got good ideas let's go and it shows up
insane reaction because I was the one
that suggested yo yo let's let's get
some high five Rush content yeah and
then that went into the red fall concert
and he he controls the tick tock he does
a whole bunch of lots so so
y'all got to start reaching for my man
like sorry
start start uh opening up this dialogue
and stop just looking at three
individuals or looking at one individual
um start because we we had a little um
like a dude ran down on us and he ran
down and he saw a cog and he's like oh
Cargill you know you this you dad I saw
you undefined to do blah blah blah oh
King oh what's up what's up what's up
half the time I make jokes addict is
making a joke with me and half the time
I do something an attic is there with me
so there's a reason why I do Arnold with
the Lord's with addict because man attic
has a report that's really crazy so
again please reach out to my man because
my man has a wealth of knowledge and
technically anytime y'all hit me in the
background your king how do I do this
stop talking to me
he does all of that right I'm asking him
to teach me how to do things right so I
just wanted to take my hat off to attic
from going to this past Pax he's been on
every time we go to shows attic has
worked very hard
this packs here is an exception because
he went above and beyond because of the
conditions that was at the actual
convention you had to take all the
information and work doubly hard so I
respect you sir and I appreciate you and
that's the reason why you know Tuesday
we got to take off you just moved and
he's still doing a ton of stuff yeah I
mean I can do it Wednesday with you on
um the attic show
yeah man again that's what I got um
saluted to the team uh successful packs
more stuff coming more fun stuff we got
some huge stuff planned don't want to
jinx it too much but stay tuned and uh
yeah man I think some more Super chats
came in and was rolled up out of here
yeah hold on a second so we got
we got sir duck remember for 30 30 32
months Lord bronze with a show we got
only fans addict to Byron and a seven
hour podcast
great show almost time for me to watch
night two of WrestleMania I just got
through I just got through watching like
two episodes of the new season of
snowfall oh that's what's up yeah I got
it I'm so behind on them shows BMF oh I
lied it was so much
tsws gaming two dollars which are attic
stays working yes actual yes no doubt
I'll be seeing you soon brother but
that's all oh
yeah baby father ten dollars to protect
speak on it king I said this several
places before dudes come on here and
don't ask AG to guest is shady as heck
stop messing with these clout chases
yeah man like I said you know how you
know I would go I've already Gotta Move
where people even come on here like if
all of us got to agree
but man they got a problem a man got a
problem with you
support everybody in the realm we're
gonna leave y'all with another one and
I'll tune into next week we up out of
here so real quick I am sending you guys
over to uh I believe one of cogs dudes
his name is Cassie plays okay uh yeah so
go over there show them live tell them
IOP sent you and uh you know he's got
one view in there you guys gonna blow us
behind yeah please
Ocarina of Time one with 50 so there
there you go social engineering we'll
check the tapes
I might have to get Byron and then
Byron check out what's going on with
this pole that this dude
not checking out any polls
we're out here
[Music]
thank you